can now it should be good now
it should be so good it's scary
who knows what that's from when we're
live they must tell us
if you build all this if you build it we
are live
tell us if you can hear us
raccadillo what's up buddy i saw your
patreon message a couple minutes ago i'm
sorry
i meant to reply recognize what's
happening buddy hello tm
bradley bledsoe bb michael burnett
okay they can hear us what's up bernie
sanders
master maverick yadao
we gotta do the name call-outs socks
talk studios vixx [ __ ]
dog taylor taylor
socks talk studios cm loves the hair
today
john thank you black chocolate laura
martinez good to see you
milan booze google scoops this is your
worst scoops i didn't see anything
steve films right there thanks for
everyone who's super chatted so far i
appreciate that go check out the
different perspectives podcast scuba
steve's been now working on that behind
the scenes
aj john in the chat oh dee's nuts
all right i'm glad to hear you're doing
okay right now rackadio
hey matthew you know art estrada
we are fresh out of a naked shower milan
gonzalez
oh yeah a naked shower definitely i've
taken so many naked showers this week
if this is your first time to a stream
here's how it works
um we're gonna pace ourselves because
i think last stream i blew out my energy
way too early
it's like 45 minutes i was so hyper and
then suddenly i was like oh no i'm
crashing and then i got a second win
like 45 minutes after that crash so
we're gonna pace ourselves hey erica
tuesday
who said scrutiny so [ __ ] that wow
that's hey
we can look at the super chats right
here oh that's so cool
oh my goodness you guys can't see this
but it's so awesome
youtube made an improvement that's
actually kind of nice
oh so we can just put this on screen
theoretically yeah
oh i love that i love theories
matthias okay so today thank you so much
all right let's kick this stream off
today is gonna be
one of those live streams that is a
topic that i'm not sure how
this topic i mean i saw some of you guys
already contributed some ideas
while we were waiting to go live and i
wasn't really sure
how well this topic would jive with
everyone i didn't know i was like yeah
you know you do something like
crossovers or something you feel like
you're bound to get a good amount of
people come in
so if this live stream stays small then
it's just going to be more intimate and
i'm totally cool with that you know
might not be the most clickety clickety
of them of like a live stream topic but
i just think it's a fun one it's one
that
constantly i think for so many movies
john and i
will always watch a film and generally
not generally every time
every single every [ __ ] movie we see
a horror movie
but a lot of movies we watch and we go
if they added horror
this would probably be a cooler movie or
i would like to see
a remade version of this uh in horror so
that's part of the thing that kind of
bummed us out about hearing the
multiverse of madness as excited as we
are
for whatever craziness the mcu is going
to be infusing
there's also this version of oh man i
was really looking forward to a
full-blown
horror mcu horror movie especially since
new mutants also didn't go full horror
yeah yeah and i think there's so many
movies you could do
with that some of these ideas i imagined
today could be like really cool
or really fun you know something like
that like with josh tranks fantastic
four
we were both big fans of what he was
originally going for yeah in the first
half of like a body horror fantastic
four
film yeah and i don't think you can do a
fantastic four
movie and make it horror but i think you
could do one of those things you know
how the boys is kind of like a riff on
justice league in a lot of ways
you could do something like that it's
kind of a riff on it
of the fantastic four like it's pretty
apparent it is
by your powers but you make it a horror
movie i think that would be a really
cool way to
sort of like bridge the gap or redo a
fantastic four movie
but make it a horror film mm-hmm yeah
man
do you have one kick us off we can't
just start going to comments right away
we gotta give peoples a little bit of
our own content yes
then rip off your guys's content i wrote
down an
with like 100 to 150 people yeah
and someday we'll do this live and it'll
be even more chaotic
like harder can you imagine doing a live
stream that's like professor xavier's
thoughts
yeah and it sort of feels like that's
that's
one thing i think you could do a
professor x uh origin movie that is one
idea then i'm gonna let john give the
idea
that there is i've i thought of like you
could do a professor x horror movie
of like especially the first time he's
really learning how to deal with these
powers
of just hearing every [ __ ] thought
being coming his way
i don't know how you decipher those
thoughts and i also imagine that
you know we have our thoughts are moving
at like we have so many thoughts
every second that in movies i find it
interesting that with the psychic
ability they hone in on just like this
one conscious thought
but i imagine if you're really reading
someone's mind and hearing their
thoughts it's gonna be like a gazillion
thoughts all at once
you know i would love to see a film that
truly cap yeah it's always one
you know like very narrative thought
where it's like the mind i'm sure
especially if you're reading the mind of
somebody who isn't very focused on
anything could be
a whole like oral experience that isn't
intelligible and yeah i would love to
see somebody actually capture that hold
on milan gonzalez
hi why are you spamming the letter e
i would just like to know that um i
wrote down a bunch of these and i've
seen already a few in the chat
so i'm not i'm trying to avoid those
there's one that's very obvious that
i've always wanted to make like an april
fool's style trailer for which is home
alone
i think just like if you just change the
music it's all right it's the most
cliche
which is why i'm changing it out change
it and i feel bad because
uh uh i i should apologize to a friend
of mine for even insinuating this but
mrs doubtfire
would make a tremendous horror movie
think about it an obsessive guy who
wants to get back with his family like
take ownership back of his kids
goes deep under like creates a whole
other identity puts himself
in makeup in disguise it's such a warm
lovely movie and yet
it could be such a horrific creepy thing
if the wrong guy
did it yeah that's true so that's one
see owen cooper gets my idea that could
be like the sixth sense but i
yeah i also think that uh
you could do a version this just popped
into my head right now
yes you could do a version of jim
carrey's yes man and make that a horror
movie
like it starts off all wonderful and
he's getting like positive
uh you know reinforcement and he's
getting some success in life but then he
starts saying yes
to some truly [ __ ] up [ __ ] do you want
us all because he agreed to yes man
do you want to join the satanic temple
yes yes do you want to sacrifice this
goat
do you want to cut off your own leg or
something
like that you know what i mean sell it
to cannibals yes all right
now it's time to hide some users because
they're being dumbasses right now in the
chat and it's annoying people
sorry guys you're gone today owen
i'm giving you one last shot is this
like sesame
street shot owen today
brought to you by several oh and
get it through your head you see
matthias rain brings up a comment that
says jurassic park could easily be
turned into a horror movie it's a horror
movie
and uh we wanted to do a topic uh some
at some point
that says um like movies that
are already secretly horror movies and
we've thought that jurassic park
i think a lot of people would agree
jurassic park in and of itself is
already a horror film and i'm surprised
it doesn't get categorized in
horror enough it just looks at it as a
horror movie
yeah part of it is scary it's because it
makes such a big first impression
i think being so wondrous and such an
achievement of things and like when it
starts out yet it really isn't trying to
clue you into the idea that it's gonna
be a horror movie and even
during parts of it the dinosaurs can
still be majestic
and wondrous and so i think yeah like it
to me
is a horror movie because it starts with
circumstances pretty normal
there's a sci-fi circumstance and then
pretty soon everything goes wrong and
the rest of the movie is scary
yes yes so to me it's already very much
horror
all right it's a monster movie i gave
him a lot of time out he can come back
in now if he wants
you know what's i thought one of one uh
this afternoon that i think could work
you remade the polar express as a horror
movie but you put mel gibson to santa
every role like tom hanks played like
six roles
now uh you do the polar express but make
it so such that
the children who get the tickets and
actually get on the train they're
spirited away to the north pole where
they're frozen as children forever and
forced to become elves
that'd be fun john yeah because like
it's already a disconcerting weird movie
to begin with
in a lot of ways and kind of creepy
because of all those tom
hanks's is uh all right john so pick any
look we're gonna go actually you know
what let's go through some of the
comments and see what you guys are
saying in here
ooh but i love that toy and ashley
hoover have a very similar
i don't no man i just read the comments
back-to-back toy and say in the movie
big daddy with adam sandler
but as a horror movie because a kid is
actually a murderer it could be like one
of those terrible
childhoods creepy child movies oh
actually there's a version of that in
the works i mean it'd be cliche as [ __ ]
but it would totally work into a certain
exp
uh cert a certain level you know there's
a movie i want to
reference in order to set this up but i
think in referencing it i will spoil it
but uh
you could remake like you know the movie
jack
yeah yeah you can make robin williams he
keeps growing up
yeah yeah yeah but he's like a kid but
he's a man yeah make a horror movie
version of that
like what i don't know i think it would
just become halloween at that point you
could just say
you can make a horror movie of that but
if you have nothing to go off of
that's not fun big you know it could be
a horror movie
you know i could say any movie didn't
say it could be a horror it could be a
horror movie
if you got okay like take take take
young michael myers or something from
the rob zombie halloween movie and make
him
you know get the instead of becoming a
murderer he gets his fortune read
wishes he was an adult so he could get
away from his terrible family he becomes
an adult
but he doesn't have good moral impulses
wow
johnny you are animals so now with an
adult body
unencumbered by this constraints of
society
this kid nick baskin or whatever his
name is in big
he can terrorize unencumbered as a white
man in
in new york that's fantastic look young
tripp
in the chat is saying sherlock holmes
why hasn't there been a
horror version of sherlock holmes it
would be i saw the devil it could be
like supernatural investigations that he
goes on or so or like legendary urban
killers like
jack the ripper or something like that
like sherlock holmes versus jack the
ripper
does not sound schlocky at all that
sounds really good that does not sound
like from hell
no but it would be cool i would still
watch it but it would be cool if you
have the jet if you have the sherlock
holmes
actually if it's actually sherlock
holmes and watson working together to
hunt down jack the ripper there's got to
be something out there that already
exists in that yeah
i'd be surprised if there isn't i guess
what i was getting at with jack is that
because there are more
because there are movies that capitalize
on that uh
uh um that condition you can have where
you
don't age and you look like a child all
your life there are movies that have
capitalized on that
you could do like the reverse but with
jack but i think it would have to hinge
on the same kind of thing as like you
got to have a kid
really messed up but he gets big erica
tuesday is saying there's a lot of robin
williams movies that could be horror
films i totally agree with that
hook is one of the creepiest movies it
makes a lot of
it's actually pretty creepy lists
actually vic's come in the chat is
saying
uh the mask and how that is originally
based on a horror uh
horror comic and if you did a horror
movie of the horror comedy i don't think
you can go
from jim carrey to just a horror movie i
think if he did a complete
comedy yeah he did a complete horror
comedy with the mask
i think that would be very exciting and
i feel like that would be a re i mean
it wouldn't it would be one of those
situations where people be like sort of
remix piece of the comic you know
but every a lot of people would
associate as a remake of the mask
but i think that would be a justified
reason to bring back the mask
if you did a horror version of it dude
what's up jim carrey pm too
yeah you could just continue the math
through a mastery and just happen to be
doing it and more twisted yeah yeah yeah
actually yeah that'd be great i think a
lot of people would tune in for that a
lot of people
really love like a horror movie of the
mask raccadillo
nightcrawler i think is already a horror
movie but he says with
paranormal elements what do you think
yeah that could be
i think it would be schlocky but i think
that would be cool and somebody else
said john wick and i also agree
because john wick you know they call him
the boogie man and you know
i don't know if it would be a
supernatural movie but i think you could
make like a really cool because like the
the the world of john wick is so dark
and full of shadows anyway
yeah you could easily make it gothic you
know
john wick yeah i mean you could do one
where down the road he's going [ __ ]
nuts
i just yeah i wanted to i want mike
flanagan
john wick where john wicks of john wick
where john wick doesn't know what plane
of reality he's existing on he keeps
seeing yeah
the ghosts of people haunting the
continentals
oh green light at netflix well that's
good that's a good one that would be
cool that would be awesome uh pandemic
jones yes
like the stream okay um we should get to
see super chats
because some people have been saying to
get to the super chat hey john can you
uh let's just do
old school just to be safe old school we
have stream labs open right now which
takes less fees so that would be much
appreciated your support means a hell of
a lot
if you can't totally cool uh but you
know your support does mean a hell of a
lot so
let's go into the thing i am saying
words waiting for this to load
words words words words words no blank
spaces
spaces uh special words words
words that [ __ ] in punch [ __ ]
yeah let's see some [ __ ] comments
baby yeah
all righty there we go and nieces number
one
as just holding it down over here hello
beautiful woman thank you our patron
saint of the youtubes hi greg hi
john hope you're having a good day
that's how i imagine you speak yeah i'm
having i'm having a good day it's been
relaxing went on a run
oh nice meditated ooh cleaned a lot last
night
got a little bit of uh just some a
little bit of additional editing to do
after this
and then maybe some writing and yeah
guys
also dan cyber put out a choose your own
adventure
thingamajiggy on his channel i'd
recommend that i was breezing through it
earlier he worked his ass off for the
past two weeks straight on it
dude john how are you adventure for dan
i don't waste a single question
john tell them how you're doing i am a
all right
i'm wearing this new t-shirt and i'm
excited because it was a gift and i
appreciate it
awesome so this is johnny you look great
in the shirt your hair
is flowing thanks you are sexually
attractive in every way
oh so are you uh i can't meet you there
it's good that we're out of frame you
know
below here
why because it would reveal the
attractions
why anatomy physiology 101
dicks it's a dick juice
big dicks of big black dicks that's
we're talking about all right
so who do we got next jump bernie
alvarado
what's up bernie thank you so much buddy
all righty
bernie says he's oh he's getting it all
all in one shot right here he's like
i'll tell you all the [ __ ] ones that
could be
that could be uh a horror movie back to
the future
oh yeah dude right there with marty and
his mom that's a horse definitely that
was a
you know back to the future was one of
the most rejected screenplays in all of
like in terms of the big movies that got
made it was one of the most rejected
stream plays of all time
and that was an element that was like
difficult to handle too
you know eric eric hey eric horseman
thanks for being here dude
um willy wonka on the chocolate factory
there's always been an underlying
creepyness to it and i
i don't know if they would ever go full
on
there's some association that i feel
like wizard of oz and return to oz and
willy wonka i think could have gone like
a little bit more for
i was hoping tim burton would push that
i was too push
creepy and weird but he didn't really
hit a
it was creepy just not in i guess all
the ways you would have hoped it could
be creepy
but i do think that yeah maybe just
because of how much
it would involve to realize a movie like
that but i think it would be perfect
to do yeah dark demented like oh don't
eat anything here because all of it is
twisted kind of movie like that would be
great national lampoon's vacation
everyone knows that chevy chase in that
movie is one step away from being jack
nicholson from the shiny he is
he really is and jumanji has a horror
film that's perfect
that would work what if they get trapped
in a horror game
yeah exactly that would be perfect right
but you still have rhys dabba here to
explain it to you i think out of all the
ones you listed bernie
a jumanji horror movie could just be a
fine one-off you know how like they're
used to
those earnest movies used to exist or
how there was like
abbott costello back in the day and they
didn't always do horror habit costello
but if you did
i feel like jumanji if they're willing
to [ __ ] around a little bit
yeah they could do that where they go
into one movie one of their movies
is a horror movie that's and that's i
feel like the
first movie like you know like we said
about jurassic park like that to me
is very much a horror movie already but
i feel like
mongi had little glimpses where i was
like oh yeah like the spider sequence
and the original one i was like yeah
easily this is a horror sequence this
could be a horror movie if just
everything was like this you know
instead of you know different
ranges of whimsy so yeah like jumanji if
they got trapped in a horror game if sam
raimi made a horror jumanji
imagine how fun that might be yeah it's
true you know
we've done giveaways in the past guys
we're giving away love
we have done giveaways in the past so
yeah we don't have one in mind right now
we're giving away give away all of
warren stuff hey maria welcome to the
chat maria
and if you spam yeah we will probably
ignore it or just block you from here
um and then who else do we got in here
we i saw i saw maria hammond
lennon oliva la pinporo
correa nate vano of course eric horseman
yay hello out in illinois gir doodle
thank you guys so much for being here
means a lot
uh let's see here what's that what's
that we go down we go down oh oh i
should be going from here the truman
show so anissa thank you my dear
yeah the truman show should definitely
be turned into a horror movie it has all
the aspects to become one
what are your hey maria hammond what are
your all's thoughts
uh yeah i mean i think truman's show
undoubtably could be a horror movie
i i don't know if they'd remake truman
show
however i do see them doing a movie
that's
like if you see the trailer for free guy
it's very easy to look at for you guy
and go
oh it's kind of like the truman show
there's a there's a it seems to be a
little bit of a hybrid right
and i think with truman taking the
concept of truman show you could
definitely do a horror version of that i
feel like they have done that have they
done that yet
not exactly where it's where it's like
clearly a riff on truman show
there's got to be something though where
it's where somebody finds out that their
life is some kind of surveillance or
yeah entertainment like there was edtv
which was a comedy but that reminded me
of a similar premise and i have to
imagine that at least there's got to be
an eddie when you said that
i was seriously thinking of ed and eddie
i saw rendering the other day of ed ed
and eddie as the three sanderson sisters
from hocus pocus
yes and i appreciated the internet for
that
the truman show would be perfect though
especially if you just dialed up the
like personal parent
like if you made it about a really
paranoid guy who
like you know kind of gets this sense
that like people are watching him all
around and everyone's like not a real
person in his life and then you just
really
you could have almost the same movie
just with totally different tones
and it would work i think okay here we
go uh
mr baju welcome to the chat
and then who else we got here mark leach
the leech
thank you mark hey guys hi mark oh hi oh
hi mark
oh i love this one oh hey guys ninja
turtles as a cronenberg
body horror yes that
would be perfect imagine just imagine
master splinter
oh god yeah man and then yeah the turtle
monstrosities
and all the fun ways that you could like
body horror differentiate them
as you know the four different you could
even cross over that ninja turtles movie
into the fly if you wanted to
sure it actually yeah if it make it some
kind of ooze time travel
uh or teleportation yeah
uh but it can't be aliens actually sl7
in the chat saying truman show was
supposed to be darker
oh maria ham i like that pitch 21 jump
street is a horror movie ah
i think they'll be doing it with high
school kids and they get in big trouble
that's always the thing i was afraid
twenty-one jump stream might go down
didn't did the mecca's direct truman
show he directed twenty one jump street
okay that's more like it i love
zemeckis's work with channing tatum let
me tell you
oh yeah and the show but at ninja
turtles
if you could do like a cool action one
if you had like a a hybrid of a nicholas
one in ref in movie
meets a cronenberg film with uh the
ninja turtles body horror only shredder
forgives
they're just mutating and they keep
getting worse and worse yeah they all
die by the end but not before
vanquishing some kind of
bigger worse monstrosity uh dan needs to
take a chill pill um
maria blew you a kiss though oh thank
you
watch hey dan listen you can go ahead
and hit that button if you want
but i'm gonna go ahead and hit that
button
oh but bye dan
howdy all right let's see here
okay just wait yeah mark leech
double punch plot for speed is just a
trap placed by
jigsaw i would would be
uh obviously curious to see that
especially how he works
with the lesson who's the thing
the thing with jigsaw is a refresher for
everyone's mind is that he always has to
have some moral lesson
for why he's putting them in a trap yeah
so what would be
the moral thing that he has actually no
he's already doing that
well yeah because there is dennis hobbes
the whole thing with dennis hopper is
he's putting him on there
as like uh the revenge form punishment
yeah i don't know why specifically it's
a bust but he did do it purposely it
would it would yes so with
jigsaw then you would have it be that
the bus driver is also in his own trap
that affects keanu reeves trap but then
keanu is in a trap but then also
several of the people on the bus are in
their own traps that are directly
like in in conflict with the kiana
reeves trap and it's just a big
death bus that's moving
there's a bunch of saw traps all over
the bus
because you know like as the saw movies
get deeper and deeper the
plot like the traps become more
elaborate and they have more moving
parts so you'll have like one trap that
involves four people doing different
things and some of those things are
individual and some of them are in a
group and then pretty
soon you've lost track and it's saw
seven and whatever
uh oh thanks maria appreciate everyone
who's showing their support in the live
stream chat right now
alex wolf some people don't get that we
can't read every single comment
at once and we'll also try to talk and
have complete sentences
because a lot of times i might be
talking or john might be talking
it could be go both ways i might be
talking i might be reading comments at
the same time and then i'm losing my
train of thought and so i'm not getting
able to give 100
to what i'm saying yeah and then john uh
might not be listening and vice versa
that happens to us
you know part of it is yeah yeah because
then you're like oh i i
yeah you take that breakfast everything
one
if we're focusing on this we got to like
answer her we gotta like give a proper
response so
some people just aren't cool with that
and i'm like well you must not have been
to a bunch of live streams man
we'll hurry it up uh let's see the
living tombstone i've
always loved that name he's got a great
channel what's up yo subscribe to living
tombstone
yep yup yup uh he says love your shirt
john non horror movies horror equal
flubber
oh dude oh flubber horror flubber hell
yeah
i was all about the movie flubber back
in the day
and uh oh by the way guys go check out
the living tombstone drunk music video
that's where all these screaming faces
are from
but uh yeah flubber i was all about
another robin williams joint too
why would that flubber be a horror movie
though well how could how could flubber
work as a horror film flubber would have
you know how flubber kind of has a mind
of its own like it'll make little
anthropomorphic blobs and stuff like
that like even though it is just a
substance that's bouncy at least a
couple times
in at least the robin williams version
it alludes to the flavor having some
autonomous qualities
it is on the verge of being like an ec
comic story yeah it could be
like like a tales from the crypt story
it is on the verge of seeing that
science yeah this is breakthrough but
then like
like i'm imagining something that maybe
borrows from the blob or something like
that because that just makes sense
visually speaking but you know yeah he's
a mad scientist and
you know like there's at least that
scene where he like falls out of a
window so you could use that
instead of for him hurting his pride as
the punchline in the actual movie goes
you can have him like break his spine
and he's trying to use flubber to like
mobilize his life back
i just want to say a flubber symbiote a
dg
a flubber body coding yeah that he could
bounce all over town in
speaking of like the flubber symbiote
joke uh speaking of the joke you know
the famous joke that goes around town
venom could have been a horror movie man
[Music]
yeah man let the devil in knock knock
like the devil in
um malevolent as i've said versus venom
slurpee says
oh that's that'd be a bouncy comedy i
wanna for the record to show we have
stated three robin williams movies so
far
they're a bit yeah there are three erica
early on in this stream in the
livestream comments
said that there's a lot of robin
williams movies that could be redone as
horror movies 12 hour photo
one hour photo john and insomnia
all right 24 hour photo and insomnia yes
uh let's see here what have we got
rakudio thank you hell
oh i got a comment to make about here
thank you racodeo i i really hope you're
doing better right now
hellboy with horror elements with the
demons you see
that's what the letdown was of the
latest hellboy remake i think everyone
who signed up for that was under the
impression as a matter of fact i kind of
know
they were under the impression that it
was going to be like way more of a
horror movie and not what we got
and while it had its like gothic
aesthetic and designs in its own way
that differentiated from the
del toro version that hellboy movie was
picked up in a way that was supposed to
be a full-blown horror movie
and i feel like that's the way to if
you're not going to bring ron perlman
and del toro back
that's the way you save that franchise
and i think people were so excited
for hellboy to become a full-blown
horror movie
when that was announced and they saw the
first images it was like damn this looks
cool
this is heavy metal oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
and then suddenly the movie we saw the
tr the trailer for
the two trailers and the movie itself
you're like oh it's not that
and i think you got to go back to that
initial excitement make it a full-blown
horror movie
the comics lend itself to that man do it
what the hell word
i see the living tombstone's obsessed
with you dude i know i just pitched a
great
flubber and that's for you i mean now
you can write the script and you can
pitch it to hollywood or make an
animation out of it with the full
original soundtrack
boogie marie in the chat said hamilton
king of comedy from owen cooper here
hamilton
uh the hulk is body horror you stole one
of mine buddy yeah
one of the ones i wanted to say today
look out oh there are
len and oliver there are a several santa
horror movies
uh there's one coming up with phil gibbs
called fat that's an action movie uh
rare exports though is a santa horror
movie
and then another one from mark leach
inside out inside
could be fun we were actually gonna i
was one of the
videos i wanted to react to uh today was
a la
la noir it's not lalla rona it's la noir
noria
something it was on alter channel and it
was it's
it's a animated horror short film from
someone who designs for pixar and i saw
the thumbnail and it did look like a
pixar movie oh wow
so uh yeah i mean now i'm excited to see
what he says here
inside out could be a psychological
thriller based around the mental state
of poor riley and what happens if joy
gets erased
dude dude that's a good one that's a
really good idea
do the array of emotions in a disturbed
mind that's a really great idea
yeah man i would be i would be very down
for that
like the thing is i feel like you could
make like a franchise out of inside out
just literally exploring different
mindsets
oh man but yeah that would be a perfect
horror movie
and then oh i love that because i
love that idea yeah cause it like you a
imagine like god what's riley gonna be
doing
hey god what are her emotions gonna be
talking about
what's gonna be happening to all our
islands uh that's a
thank you mark leach that's just a cool
idea waiting to happen
yeah that's another i feel like there's
a lot of these ideas
especially with horror and some of the
ones that you guys have been staying in
the chat today
that undoubtedly even if you can't do an
actual
like inside out horror movie you could
do a movie that's
that's your pitch you know it's like
inside out plot but it's a horror movie
yeah
and here's how it would work like that's
an actual movie idea that could come to
fruition that's pretty cool
and we love seeing movies that deal with
like going into the mind dream stuff
inception the cell
matrix you know [ __ ] like that so i
think you could actually uh i think you
could actually pull that off that'd be
awesome hey slurpee
i like how people are saying it it's
just without the comedic stuff
you knew that we would get a few of
those ooh conair yes
mimi m saying stranger than fiction that
is a good call
uh toy story i think would also yeah
pretty good i mean sid if you just made
it all about sid
then it's a horror movie omni media
michael b thank you buddy
omni hope you've been kicking so much
ass lately
ooh drinking some wine watching a pair
of handsome boys
did you know imagine he's watching the
stream from his television
yeah with a fire roaring in the
background and he has some kind of
1800 scotch entertain me
live did you know they made an official
banana splits horror movie i watched
that show growing up
what is banana splits to the google i
couldn't explain it well
to the google i i i only have the vagus
of recollections of of banana splits and
not enough to uh
to properly explain it to you well while
we're while you're looking that banana
split hold on a sec john while i look at
banana splits i'll read the comments as
a coming in real time
yeah adam's family has always been a fun
horror kevin shepard says i want
straight art house and violence
adam's family version of it but wouldn't
that
completely strip away the whole thing
that makes adam's family adam's family
but then again they are like a super
they wouldn't just be like some cult
family like a manson family they are
they are halloween people yeah exactly
and it would further separate them from
the monsters
okay yeah there you go point proven um
and i think you could do a madam's
family movie and just lean
way more into the horror which is
actually scary but you could still keep
it like
charming and cute yeah it would almost
become like a like a house of a thousand
corpses thing where it's like where i
was going well because you have a
deranged family with a predilection for
torture and and you know murderous
delights so like
you know them on their own they're just
like chilling and having fun and then
it's like when other people from the
outside world interact with them that's
when it gets
scary i remember this movie coming out
the banana splits movie
from a year or two ago i i've never seen
it but there are these big fluffy
characters and i'm gonna drag this
window just so that all
y'all like us who don't know can see
this is the banana splits movie right
here and uh there is yeah there's
there's the one i heard good things
about this too
uh but yeah this looks easily like
nightmare fuel
uh darth yoda which commentary are you
trying to get me to read
there's one that darthy that uh rosie's
trying to get me to read
ooh hancock say the name and hopefully
my eye catches it in time as i'm
switching around here
johnny say the name let's uh we gotta
honor some of the super chats uh
of the stream labs now clipping but yeah
louis
i just tagged them in chat yeah saga
trying to make sure i don't miss some
comments especially ones that
we will i'm probably just gonna ask
rosie to moderate for us one day
we we we're gonna have to bring rosie
onto the payroll
rosie already needs backup uh
let's see let's see okay let's get okay
that's 10 10. we're we're getting close
guys
we're we're back okay flev the flev
there we go
toy is saying sleepless in seattle or
you got mail
i was supposed to definitely fit in with
the creepy stalker genre
you've got mail could be a great one
there needs to yeah i was i was
i was gonna ask like yeah to take one of
those movies
i would love to see a movie start out
genuinely as a romantic comedy and
slowly without like telegraphing it
twist into some kind of
yeah horrible uh whoa you could do
like it's like heat where you're
focusing on the good and bad guy
equally yeah well you could do it or
you're focusing on the serial killer and
the woman equally
or vice versa that would be even cooler
actually i prefer the flip where it's a
guy
and the girl's the killer yeah and this
is the you've got male story
but you're watching it in in that guy's
unwittingly playing into this path
that that's i feel like the the red eye
trailer
like ruined the movie iteration of this
concept by being so convincingly like oh
it's gonna be a light remember oh
goodness no killian murphy but the whole
thing when you've got mail is you're
you're watching both of their
perspectives back and forth yeah they
don't know and it's not like it's all
built
you've got male is like the third one i
think of that franchise
of that uh pairing no no no no like of
the actual concept
oh yeah i forgot what the first one was
called
shop around the corner figure out which
one you've got a papyrus
that i got a letter from the post office
you've got a telegram
you've got to scroll
flavours chase garner in the chat saying
incredibles as a horror that is like
what my fantastic four would be kind of
like that
oh and damon pewdiepie uh casper
yeah if you did casper but just scary
that would be great
uh who do we got who's the first uh we
got phleb doran back to back thank you
flev says hi guys i missed last week's
dream cause i fell asleep
why do we need sleep anyway in the
immortal words of the bare naked ladies
who needs sleep well you're never gonna
get it
i like that you take the time out to
give your words of wisdom john and for
this week
not the most original idea oh too bad we
already got this one
willy wonka the chocolate factory could
easily be straight up slasher
film removed the songs couple of tweaks
here and there and boom bada bing
you got yourself a scary willy wonka
what the [ __ ] else you want huh yeah
what are you talking about willie walker
in the chocolate factory
what are you doing stupid fat kids you
get your mouth out of my chest chocolate
right and fat kids over here
this kid's got too much tv charlie you
want the factory or not take the [ __ ]
factory it's clearly you're the only one
apparently robert de niro has willy
wonka
you know you want to see that for okay
next month of november because there's
no you know
theme there uh we can do movies that
otto have been crime movies
movies that we're thankful for pikachu
as a horror movie matthias is saying
yeah it's a badass idea yeah yeah where
it's like you know the ghost of
someone's deceased father possesses
pikachu
and then like you know possesses their
way i think you could do pokemon horror
man
yeah those guys those animals one day
they're going to rebel
yeah they're going to be like why are
they [ __ ] forcing us to fight like
slaves to live in balls and fight each
we work together
we can overtake we just want to chill
out and be pokemon this could be our
world and the humans could be our pets
what the [ __ ] do they do for us we can
get our own food it's because they have
some of the
they pokemon mastered vocabulary yet
except for meowth you know meowth is the
next link in pokey evolution i like
osmosis joan as a [ __ ]
as a body horror sam that's a great one
queen anisa
thank you queen anisa oh yeah hey john
look
she has your idea home alone into a
horror movie where kevin grows up into
being like
jigsaw i would like to go watch i will
thank you anissa for that
and didn't they do that there's a show
here this is a short film with uh
macaulay culkin where he played
a guy who's already gone direct he's a
jigsaw mode but he he just because
there's a guy yeah he becomes this
deranged like rideshare driver
who's like totally traumatized from his
experience and then
when people try to like rob them in
their car he i'm totally giving away
anyway it's a good job go watch it
it's a good horror film as kevin
mcallister already and he's in it if you
haven't seen it it's a really funny
short so anissa
wish granted it's a it's a youtube
search a wii
uh flev is back thanks buddy
what we got apparently there's
controversy with the home alone opinions
in this stream
how could you think of home alone like
that anisa
aye it's a pure innocent film a kid that
protects his house by creating this
intricate dangerous traps that really
harm the bandits and he seems to have
no emotions doing it oh my god my
childhood is a lie
yes it is see kevin kevin is
i i love the pitch meeting for that
movie because it is true like the family
is the worst
and kevin is also the worst i mean i did
a video
i don't know if i put it only on patreon
or if i did put it on youtube too
but i did a video of how i wanted to see
a home alone
reboot that was 10 episodes long it was
a mini series
and it's a slow deliberate pace thing
and that's a descent into madness
where you you're building up to the to
the night where they go away that takes
place over like three episodes
yeah yeah yeah so it's yeah episodes
episode one would end when they leave
the family leaves okay so
two through whatever like six would be
where he's like
uh uh you know slowly starting like
embracing it but starting to go insane
and he
gets himself involved in drugs and
hookers yeah and he's like this 14 year
old kid right but he's
and then you would have um uh
yeah and then in the last and then
you're slowly teasing the two criminals
there
who are like murderers they're not just
thieves you know and then and then the
last three episodes would deal with
the actual invasion yeah or the last
episodes of torture and then
kevin mcallister shot by the cops yes
exactly
put the shotgun down and [ __ ] it was a
bb gun
well yeah no no it's because one rookie
cop makes the mistake of stepping onto
like the front lawn and then a trap goes
off and they just light the house up
we must have been confusing anyone who's
tuning into the stream right now because
we have bradley's comment highlighted
this whole time while we're talking
about home alone
i see somebody said chappie and horror
absolutely yes
toy story is already kind of horror
movie would sid man yeah it's just the
sid perspective
uh let's see here bradley bledsoe hey
guys
thank you bradley chatting back and
forth we're going to work together on
something very soon
hey guys i think it would be interesting
to see the batman villas
villain scarecrow give a psychological
horror treatment
you could have some ordinary gotham
citizens
uh as the main characters and they
follow
okay and they fall into scarecrow's trap
love you guys stay
safe it would be cool to see a gotham
city movie that involves a villain
people being victimized by the villain
and then batman is an outside force that
really does swoop in and
save them that like when you see batman
finally it's like oh god
thank you breath of fresh air so you're
saying there should be a movie
like free guy but it's a dude in gotham
like what it's like to be a guy living
in gotham city
that's not how i would handle it i would
handle it that way you know me okay
would it be ryan reynolds
would he be that charm he would be
completely unaffected by god
completely terrified man um well i did
pitch on movie fights the whatever the
i think the video is called like who's
the best joker uh of the title and i did
pitch
a scarecrow horror movie idea that i had
that i
i think you could do one of like when
he's a kid and just focus on him as a
kid with
his relationship with his scientist dak
is that that's such a big part of his
origin and his knowledge of
developing the toxins and stuff at least
in one of the later renditions of the
character
because the earlier rendition of
scarecrow is just he's a professor who's
obsessed with fear and then he
kind of cracks at a he's teaching a
class and he brings a gun in there he's
fired and he wants revenge so he becomes
a thief
but my version i want to see kind of
like i've always thought the tone would
be
kind of a kid to carry but you're
focusing on a guy dealing with bullying
who's pushed into this place and then
at the end of it he gets revenge against
the bullies yeah you see how
dark and mad cruelty can go yeah man uh
rosie and he goes to school with bruce
wayne
and then he causes his parents to get
killed
hey rosie uh said if they don't find it
then try again
apparently there's something we need to
find so drop it in the chat right here
and there you go matthias rain have not
seen gotham city by gaslight but would
love to i have not seen gotham by
gaslight but there's a version of what
you're talking about with i think
there's batman gotham knights which
the gotham knight which i think is kind
of explores that idea of what you're
talking about not really in full blown
horror
but yeah but yeah but just as an intense
like wolverine body horror movie
rackadio saying you know what that
that would just basically be the day he
gets the adamantium put into him
yeah and you just focus on that it's
like passion of the christ but with
wolverine getting
oh that adamantium put into him although
imagine that
just had that little detail of like yeah
my feet my hands heal every time i
retract the claws so
every time they come back out i'm just
cutting myself again
so so dark and michael b we did pitch
that scarecrow
thing i'm really apparently bradley
blitzeau's really attached to the
scarecrow care
script and i'm really attached to mine
because i did pitch that before guys
then
it's a race to see who can get it
greenlit first ooh damon pewdiepie in
the chat is saying the two-faced horror
movie
that would absolutely be awesome
yes i would be so down for it all you
have to say is two-face horror movie
and i feel like all of us could kind of
get an idea what that would be right
away here's the way
pretty obvious here's what you do you
make it one of those
movies where it's him the whole time but
but to sell it
and to make us wonder you only shoot him
from one side so that when the big
reveal comes it was him all along that's
been doing these horrible things
and then he turns his face and we see
the crispy side
okay that sounds great thank you for
dignifying that
well it just has me thinking okay lewis
if we're going to refresh the super
chats and if it's not there then we'll
uh we'll make sure to
i'll make sure to single you out here oh
we'll just screenshot it in the meantime
one second we'll make sure to answer it
okay
all right but i'll see okay
but i i'm thinking that uh with
the dc villain verse that they wanted to
do more of those like joker things but
actually
you know get the perspective of the
villain do it from the perspective of
the villain if they
even if they tie in batman like harvey
dent so much of his origin is connected
to batman
uh at least the time of batman you know
yeah so
um i think that you could do a movie
where you are focusing on uh like harvey
dent
watching to morph into two-face and
having to deal with like this temptation
to become a criminal he ultimately gives
in to this other
side yeah but i think you could do that
with so many especially if
you could do that with marvel villains i
think especially though with dc villains
because they're willing to go a little
bit darker especially right now you know
yeah definitely it seems like i they're
willing to go
darker i'm willing i'm waiting to see
when they like completely embrace that
as part of their palette versus
something we do
on a very specific joker occasion yes
we didn't finish reading these no we
didn't which is why i i just wanted to
see the other
uh super chat menu in case i could zero
in on lewis's in the background
um but let's see where are we where are
we
uh we got screaming
air conditioner screaming scream queen
anisa right there
okay hear me out yeah like batman
quarter alice horror movie see you're
getting it yeah
and a marvel zombies if marvel did that
now oh man dude
your animated one put it on disney
let's see how that goes poured it out on
hulu keep it keep it quiet that it's
disney
okay hear me out the cars franchise is
set
after an ai uprising a horror movie out
of this children's movie will be what we
all needed the cars franchise yes
it would be like christine's
yeah man all the cars have a spirit
we're at war with the cars
john carner but we reprogrammed
lightning mcqueen
to be on our side he's the fastest car
there is
he can he can convince them all how
would they burst each other
by crashing crashing into each other or
by doing like
extended ben juresque sequences where
they're just trying to ram one another
off the road
i think do it i agree
danny dipple thanks for being in the
chat danny dibs
that's hilarious anisa thank you and
she's also saying uh thank you anissa
ferris bueller's day off
made into a horror movie about an
imaginary best term from cameron's side
of the story where ferris never
existed so his imaginary friend
didn't go to school yeah you just never
see that
side or there is i i think
a lot of these movies you could just
remake and just have them do way more
[ __ ] up
things yeah what if they murdered a guy
when they
took the car yeah yeah yeah and then
they
the first of those days about them i'm
going to bury you hide a body
yeah and like deal with the car and
avoid cut it would be like a weird and
not nightcrawler exactly but i'm just
imagining an experience that becomes
nightcrawler-ish
yeah i like it i want it great thanks
anisa that's a funny one
killchow all right let's check in with
the
let's check in with people here with our
peeps
nothingness is saying it's for marvel
ultron would be a good horror movie
see that's what i mean in terms like age
of ultron
that would have benefited if you didn't
make him funny
which well i did find charming at the
time admittedly
no strings at the same time though if
you may if you when you did the ultron
stuff whenever you were checking in with
ultron
if you actually had a real horror touch
to it
that would have made age of ultron a
million times better
yeah there's a version of the stream
that we could have titled movies that
would have been better if you added
horror
yeah yeah and age of ultron is one of
them age of ultron if you is
added horror it would have been better
because then think of how much more
triumphant vision would be yes the
vision would be like the light in the
darkness
so you get it yeah man i'm all for this
mark call kevin feige up and tell him
he's stupid you get it he gets it he's
stupid
kevin feige not me being john malkovich
alice alistair campbell is saying who
framed roger rabbit
directed by jordan peele actually would
be a great david fincher one to do ooh
an investigative murder story yeah
people with tunes
yeah i want i want to see david fincher
have to tackle that territory
starring brad pitt yeah
sorry brad pitt get robert downey jr
back in a dramatic role yeah
you know let's see what let's what else
do we have here harry potter as horror
they kind of have their horror touches
throughout
yeah which always makes me sad that
during halloween time they don't do like
a nocturnally thing at universal where
they have like
death eaters on stilts and dementors and
stuff you know
when i put in the
uh when i when i installed peacock the
other day
to watch abbott costello meet
frankenstein they said
halloween uh hogwarts halloween or
something like that
yeah of like the harry potter movies
they selected to watch during halloween
and it was all the harry potter movies i
was like you should just call this
the harry potter movie yeah this is
every
halloween every harvest every harry
potter movie
they are increasing their traffic by
clever use of alliteration
uh let's see right here yeah truly i
mean like the harry potter movies do
lend themselves
so i guess in a tangential way do it
we'll get to everyone but i want to make
sure because chase we did miss yours
it's not popping up here
uh john where where did his go do do you
do you see it i screenshotted it and now
i can't find it
no i don't see it john what happened
john john i'm scared it's okay greg
we're going to get through this together
i'm scared john
is darling scared his friends let's
check the one of the other screens
oh my god i'm looking at photos of
myself right now you guys can't see it
yeah
oh you're in a you're in a little thingy
you're in a thing hey oh
well i mean louis i think sent it again
just find the screenshots and make sure
i don't like the idea that we're losing
screenshots
all right all right there we go ideas
switch it to date
it's right there okay so lewis i want to
make sure you send it you said you sent
in a super chat about 20 minutes ago but
it never showed up in the chat you've
been charged oh it doesn't even say what
it is all right
yeah yeah just put the comment back in
there
all right all right all right all right
so uh uh we can either go back to the
super chat menu or we can
we can jump to lewis really quick
because i see his right here
all right what do you say he said let's
try again here let's bring up the screen
so we'll pop you in and everything we'll
give you the full treatment
it's going to look a little janky
because this is coming from the chat
chat
but uh we didn't need to do all this we
didn't need to do you know we're just
going to read it
it's very confusing we're just going to
read it because youtube is really trying
to make you feel special for myself i
want
the effort is really much appreciated
but now it's just looking like a cluster
but it is a a cluster of
of ours all right i'm just using the
regular
there we go let's try again he said a
horror set in the
avatar the last edward airbender world
where a house of crazed benders
torment a group of non-gender teens
holy crap wow that that would be i
don't know if anyone who that would end
absolutely horrifying dude
is that because well let's repeat this
if you guys can't see the comment
a horror set in avatar the last
airbender world
where a house of crazed benders torment
a group of non-gender teens
the last part is so specific i i feel
like i'm missing something it's d
i've only seen three episodes of avatar
the last airbender so i'm having a
little bit of a difficult time
fully wrapping my head around this idea
but from what i've seen in the show
uh that sounds oh no no non-bender he
said it is it's
there's a follow-up that got hidden
because of the words yeah i was like
[ __ ] what's with the non-gender [ __ ]
non-gender was meant to be non-bender
that seems really bad
you guys can't see the sunscreen but he
clarifies
all is forgiven i'll i'm not going to
try and show to you
no you know i will i'm going to make way
more i will show you you are exhausted
this is really
right here inside of the benders yes so
evil evil deranged benders go in and
just you know wreak havoc
on poor non-bender folks i was like wow
yeah yeah that was a really dark comment
that we've been hunting down
i feel like there that that is a
template that you could use
is yeah take anything that involves like
a group of powered people that has
various factions and just what happens
like you could do that with harry potter
as if you just had a movie that's all
about muggles
except now they're death eaters
descending upon them you know like that
could be a horror movie
yeah but yeah non-non-gender
wow okay that's crazy
apocalypse from death star kitty in the
chat that does sound yeah lego this is
the end
all right so they should make it that
way
yeah scroll a bit upward mic will be
pandemic jones
not yet uh here we go who who's that
really john jambos jambos
we should punch it john what happened
fixed we
every time you adjust something it's not
you every time the thing adjusts it it
like
completely remixes the boom the scale
all right home alone 30 years later
just so surprised i haven't that one
typo
i was sitting there thinking okay this
is so again
specific but it's got to be a typo
i just couldn't imagine how and i feel
like it was right under my nose
i was surprised that rosie was also like
hunting us down to make sure we're not
hunting us down but really making sure
that we saw it yeah yeah
um all right are you gonna stand for
this
yeah uh home alone
30 years later 30 years later og cast
horror comedy yeah yeah
home alone seems to be the most it's
been robin williams movies
a wide a white filmography of robin
williams
and different iterations of horror that
you can do from home alone
yeah man it's it's gonna happen now it's
so in the in the cultural consciousness
that
it's only a matter of time i would let
me add on to this jam boost thank you
for the super
chat uh i would say that it would be
cool to see home alone
this 30 years later version but also
have the
cast from red letter media star in it
since they collab together a lot
yeah they can be the new wet band they
could be the new or they could be like
uh yeah that could be something they
could be something
pandemic jones pandemic jones
oh this is what you mean i saw i just
saw one of your comments in the
in the chat here saying how you were uh
that we already said yours
um picture a hairy but thank you anyway
picture a harry potter film
you can make an argument that they
definitely go through some scary things
in the movies yes they do but a hoarding
wizarding world would be dope in my
opinion
no you could do one that's like escape
from azkaban yeah
yeah or just like anything that's like
super hi ricky welcome to the chat
super rooted in the world of the death
death eaters yeah
and harry potter horror anime well
a [ __ ] anime of harry potter think of
the possibilities
especially with so good especially with
how incredible like the
marriage of of you know drawn or at
least you know
traditional looking animation with cg
lately like i watched an episode of
demon slayer the other day that had like
mind-blowing effects that would lend
themselves so well to magic
like that that would be it was really it
was an anime horror
of harry potter that's the next gotta
get that done man that'd be great
i want more anime adaptations of stuff
like the dementors like tm is saying
yeah
yeah dude dementors and all the like
there
are you know you got nocturne alley like
there's so many like
devices and trinkets and just trappings
and creatures in the harry potter world
that are dark
yeah you know all right so what do we
got next here
i'm surprised like if they're making the
trench for aquaman they can do a harry
potter side quest
uh i haven't seen eric horseman even
talking with anyone in the chat hope
he's all right
eric are you are you drunk yet well i'm
just noticing that he's i haven't even
seen him like popping in his his name
popping eric
he's watching blind manners he's
probably watching blind man he's
watching
man he's like i don't have time to
listen to you guys the juicy
bandit is saying i love to see pixar
movies with horror themes
like toy story would be ideal or
possibly monsters inc
with a really gritty take realistic
gritty take
it's funny how much pixar does kind of
lend themselves to horror you got coco
which could definitely be horror dealing
with the afterlife trying to find it it
could be like what dreams may come in
the hell sequence another robin williams
movie
or it could be uh or monsters inc
i mean part of the fun is that they're
not actually scary but if you did a
version of that where you
you could have like uh that when it's
actually supposed to be
monster scares you make it actually
scary yeah that would be a pretty neat
version of it
or like they're not just trying to
collect screams to power their society
they want to actually eat these kids
or if you did a toy story movie but the
whole thing is sid's perspective
yeah exactly you capture it all from sid
of course the toys are moving
like did that toy move you know the toys
come to life at the end
they have him trapped they're trying to
kill him he breaks out yeah exactly and
then he's just overpowered by all the
toys around
she's banging on the window trying to
get to his neighbor andy's you know
yeah now riddle me this
wood he's trying to kill me i have a toy
story question
like there are a lot of logical rules i
think you could poke at for toy story
especially in the light of toy story 4
but i have one major question which is
toys come to life
and i feel like there's a relatively
thin line
between a lot of toys that are you know
the likenesses to human beings and
for example like a statue of somebody
so like would a statue come to life in
in the toy story world like if you had a
paperweight
that looked like edgar allan poe would
it come to life because technically it's
not toy but it's also just a small
trinket made of material that's like
amusing and
and implies some sort of slight
narrative
do you see where i'm going with this i
see where you're going
what are the rules this is how we keep
the live stream on track
yes with off topic with hot topic music
can we
question the rules of toy story for the
next few minutes
that's what the topic implies i'm just
joking that was actually great and i
just didn't know what to contribute so i
just made fun of you you know how i do
john
i know i know how i do i gotta have
something i just can't end i
just can't go good job i've i've decided
lately that if greg's making fun of me i
must have won
this must be a side of myself that's the
way to do it man
um uh ricky is asking the chat the lie
what do what do you guys see when you
click on the on the stream the live
stream
uh like what does it pop up in your feed
at the live stream is just basically
like
films franchises remakes that could be
done to infuse horror into movies to
make them better or just interesting or
even funny
anything that you think could be saying
horror mean girls
it's called heathers it is yeah have you
made
heather's like less uh sarcastic and
more just frightening yeah
although uh i would also venture to say
uh the craft
the craft is a lot like that although
you would have to switch the perspective
because
the thing is like they're not the
weirdos if they're the plastics you know
they're they're the top of the food
chain
right mr uh yeah oh toy is
answering your question he's saying and
toy story before they explained it with
forkey
because woody didn't understand how
trash could become a toy
well they didn't explain it it was just
more like how did trash become a toy
must be the thing you associate give
give you got to give
otherwise toys would just be going
bananas sandwich all the time yeah
that's true
they should do a toy story during covet
yes
where the toys never get to come to life
they're just trapped in different
[ __ ] cavey toys [ __ ] yeah they're
trapped in stores they've got nothing to
do
the ones that are at home are going nuts
because the kids in the room
most of the time yeah uh torturous toys
our art our rx mies is saying an
r-rated hocus pocus movie modern day
generation
yeah anisse is saying i'm going to chill
this week because i got a call from my
bank last time oh
that's so good no that's a-okay but also
it's just that's that's pretty funny
that's actually appreciate your support
but
you know anytime you you like give a lot
i i i tend to message anita afterwards
and be like
hey it's okay so you don't have to do so
thank you i appreciate it it's very
appreciated appreciate the heads up
just love having you here yeah keep
talking i like when the people in the in
the stream keep chatting
i see somebody said ghostbusters but
with more horror and i would like to go
one further and say they should make a
luigi's mansion movie
and make it spooky oh yeah because
that's how you should just kick off the
mario franchise right away
luigi's mansion yeah we'll do a luigi
movie then a waluigi movie then
wario talk
mario the first avenger yeah yeah yeah
the fourth movie will be about toad then
we'll do princess peach and
all culminate to go get mario uh let's
see
here niraj krishnan thank you what's up
buddy
yes while you were sleeping
a sandra bullock movie from the 90s i'm
not familiar with while you were
sleeping
i think you could do the proposal though
um to add to this oh yeah you could do
the proposal
where sandra bullock pressures
um ryan reynolds into
getting married to her so she could stay
in the states and not lose her work and
such and threatens to fire him if he
doesn't do it
you could do the proposal
as like a [ __ ] up workplace thriller
of a woman forcing a man to marry her
yeah to be like misery but in the
workplace
yes perfect see yeah huh
oh man you know what and it's about him
that's the
arc of the character is it's him
learning to not let his trauma from his
mom dictate
this situation he's in and overcome it
and stand up and do the right thing and
lose his
job send her ass to jail he becomes it's
a male empowerment
yes don't let yourself be taken
advantage of
moving man and and yeah don't let
yourself become an
object boy yeah men are suffering left
and right
don't be objectified by women this is
the movie we need to do
what the [ __ ] is while you were sleeping
it is a hopelessly romantic
chicago a hopelessly romantic chicago
transit authority token collector
is mistaken for the fiance of a coma
patient
oh boy that does sound potentially
horrific
that works there too especially if she
tries to exert
physical like ownership over him while
he's in a coma
yeah yeah he'd be creepy
damn that's like a [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
is
that's like yeah you could do overboard
as a horror movie
it's like a kidnapping scenario all
right guys let's break away from
the horror topic for just one minute to
talk about this yes
john who was saying that cjw j
with the dubs cjw what would you guys
like to see in the hbo max green lantern
show
been watching you guys since 100k
i want them to take all the adult [ __ ]
that they do from doom patrol
all the sex and the swearing just
basically seeing the adult
lifestyle of what it's actually like
within the core the like oh really
seeing the workplace
the day-to-day watching like these
different type like this creature and
this creature
and they have like a weird [ __ ]
sexual
relationship where they just can't
commit to each other or
um a human and and and a creature you
know that that's what i would want to
see is like
uh just a real adult [ __ ] go on
in the green lantern corps take time to
not just be missions and big stakes [ __ ]
but really uh uh to some adult
relationship stuff
because i think you can get away with
that when it comes to like no one really
knows doom patrol we can do it
you know [ __ ] it why the hell not um but
you can't
do that well you don't imagine that with
green lantern and i feel like it would
just be such a shocking thing to infuse
if you went that adult in the green
lantern show yeah dude take it
full advantage of your hbo ness and in
the process i want like the
whole score to be like cool acoustic
dark
like outlaw songs yeah like that you
know go full hbo about it
see it works man yeah and uh it's like
that's why like
lennon in the chat saying herogasm for
boys like boys can get away with it but
i think when you associate that like
there's certain ones you just don't
your mind won't go there it's like they
have
in doom patrol one of them he's not part
of the original doom patrol but they put
him in the show they
have cyborg and they go hardcore
body horror with him in the first season
they do a lot of
like real body horror with him it's
disturbing it's scary
i like the sound of that and you don't
you wouldn't expect that
but to do that if it were with him and
so i think doing this with movie you
know just like boobs and stuff
he smells boobs in my [ __ ] green
ladder show man
and i want them to cast jon stewart to
play jon stewart
chris wham-off is saying chris i'd love
to see the smurfs get scary who the [ __ ]
would it want to see
yeah watch gargamel go crazy
yeah yeah and then all the smurfs like
oh you could do it where like gargamel
there are hallucinations of his and he's
like going insane and the smurfs are
each like different uh fragmented parts
of his uh tortured soul
i just want to see the plot of it
follows but with smurfs
it smurfs it smurfs
yeah man that would work just every one
of those weird sex ghosts gets replaced
by a giant blue
you know how they have these like lego
version movies yes
of things like that ryan was making in
the boys yeah i want to see
uh one i want to see the smurfs do that
but with adult horror films
yeah yeah just just swap out it's a swap
oh oh oh not pornhort
not porn adults just just horror films
where did you get that from
you said adult horror films like horror
films for adults yeah yeah i get you now
i i took that a little too
kids shouldn't be watching it follows i
mean my kids will my kids
that'll be the first horror i'm going to
feel like let's pop on this new
streaming that'll be our birds and the
bees talk
this is called shutter yeah still around
not a lot of people know that
yeah if you got amazon um
hey eric i see his name hey i see pedro
jose wants a doctor strange's horror so
did we all
ah let's see here tim neal is saying in
the chat how about a psychological
horror movie a sleepless in seattle
where it's slowly revealed that tom
hanks character is a serial that hunts
his victims through his radio show
boom boom that yeah i'm down you nailed
it buddy
you nailed it we need a tom hanks horror
movie
yeah it's called saving private riot
it's called the burbs it's called
greyhound uh
bradley blitz so thanks dude i think a
scooby-doo horror comedy
or scooby-doo murder mr be very
interesting what do you guys think
i mean i don't know about you but that
scoob movie
was not easy for me to sit through not
gonna lie oh don't
really do it don't let that taint your
whole
image of the scooby-doo and that's the
only scooby-doo thing i've ever
actually sat through as god intended but
i was
into the first 15 minutes when they are
doing some like supernatural go spooky
[ __ ]
good investigation and i think if they
double down on that
like gave scooby doo to leica
i think you could have a really [ __ ]
and scooby-doo horror
like movie that could actually be scary
when it needs to be i am about
the the like of scooby-doo also night
alistair
good night oh you're named after that
great guest star from supernatural
the one who talks like this john
you talk about scooby-doo horror please
dude scooby-doo
on monster island actually kind of
scared me as a kid so i have long been
and that's like a great animated like
halloween time movie so i would say that
yes i am
all down for a new scooby-doo horror
comedy
in fact if they did it roger rabbit
style i would like that even better
and uh you know it could be a murder
mystery and a horror comedy why stop it
both
or don't stop be both john you did it
you talked about
scooby doo i'm proud of you judas
thunder steals some of the skinny anime
movies are awesome you stay where my
friend
the juicy bandit back at it again this
is a great one
this is a great one yes honey i shrunk
the kids would be an amazing horror film
yes
that is terrifying in cons
it's all about execution because that
really is
terrifying in concept oh goodnight mark
leech it is terrifying
night mark like and think of the
potential ramifications like of making
somebody so small
so quickly you know like that's got to
have like a ton of repercussions on your
on your body and then like they're
teenager kids are
they think their parents are gone and so
like the daughter brings up a guy
yeah she's like secretly like doing
heroin with yeah
banging and then it shows how parents
are watching it like no i need to get
out of this pillow
i'm stuck in the pillow then
i'm stuck in the cushion underneath both
of their pelvises
uh yeah man it would be awful that's
your ant-man horror movie
yeah you just secretly revealed that in
the background this whole time the
teenagers have been living depraved
lives how [ __ ] cool would that be i i
agree
i'm with it and i think rick moranis
should come out of retirement for it but
it's
i think you can make that a horror
comedy honey i shrunk the kids yes
it's scary in concept it really is oh
yeah cause think of all the like
horrible things that could try and eat
you when you're small
think of just the bug [ __ ] you could do
uh honey i shrunk the kids here
uh and then thank you buddy and then we
got
chase gardner who saying i love the way
this is said
at least this is how i read it bad boys
will smith can have some more
yeah throw some uh throw some horror why
not no reason why not
put some horror in there give him a
little horror maybe maybe that'll uh
bring him back
men in black some horror actually black
would be great
the first one actually has some moments
that are tense yeah and yeah
like whoa what what the heck and you
know they're they teeter on getting to
horror and certain scenes
and i think you could do that with yeah
they if they had men in black actually
be scary yeah
oh dude that would be a way like it's
weird that you can revitalize a lot by
just adding fear
if you if you added [ __ ] like because
that makes it exciting
yeah you know it's if you if you wanted
to continue men in black and you made a
horror a part of it like actually scary
that'd be real i think that would make
people um excited to check out a men in
black movie
dude uh but so yeah maybe not bad boys
well i think bad boys could use a little
bit more
tension i think uh perhaps men in black
out those franchises that could actually
use an infusion of horror but think
about this
what if the bad boys had to track down
jigsaw
and then they both get put into trap and
the trap is
they're together in the trap so they
have to work as a team to get out of the
trap and then kill jigsaw and have a
cool like you know
john that might be one of the best ones
those are the best ones i heard
i'm here all stream t1 is pitching one
of the breakfast
club where they're locked down trapped
in there ooh yeah
over an entire weekend of snow school
and then you mix that in with honey i
shrunk the kids
i shrunk the parents the students um
who uh who's that jay terro j edgar
hoover that is
j j edgar who jay tavo j tavo
john take it away ah a jack the
ripper-esque slasher set in the
wizarding world as a serial killer uses
a variety of spells to manipulate and
torment people
in a london dude yeah
they had shades of that kind of oh but
through london
you get a glimpse of that like a little
bit at the beginning of like the seventh
movie or whatever but yeah you can have
it where there's a character
who's um like murdering people and they
need like they have a hogwarts meeting
yeah you know we need to hunt down
whoever this killer
is who's often people using magic yeah
actually it's not a bat that's a cool
way to do it and then you could bring in
a new like horror hero who's like oh
cool because he's
only he specializes in like the darkest
dark wizards
i think you know what would be great for
hbo max to do is
uh a harry potter hog like a harry
potter anthology show
yeah that not so maybe not based on hair
like
you're following harry potter but you do
that way not everything needs to be
about like a giant deep delve into lore
and not everything has to have a
voldemort yeah not everything needs to
be a
world-ending state yeah you could do
something like that or it's a one-off of
that
um you could really mix it up where uh
you know like that way you could do like
more contained harry potter so because
like there's no way they do a contained
harry potter movie
you know but if you did something like
this where it's a lot smaller like the
way it definitely hollows part one
is the most contained or low scale of
them all yeah but do it even
lower your hbo max they could really
restrict the anthology one that'd be
cool
yeah i'd be down plus you know with
their effects budgets they could do
magic and stuff a lot you know
uh let's well thank you thank you buddy
toy story where they are actually
immortal vampires
that live off of children's joy a pure
nightmare
oh if the toys are mortal do they die
is so just children just playing with
some dead corpses
oh that's one i gotta read this again
toy story where there are actually
immortal vampires
that live off of children's joy a pure
night
how is that a nightmare or if the toys
are immortal
do they die if so just children playing
with some dead corpses
so okay this sounds like
uh this sounds like a a gothic
drama because most kids
stop playing with their toys they
usually get bored and move on and get
locked away
if they if they're emotional vampires
and they only are able to stay alive
due to the joy that they provide the
child they'd all
die so they'd just be withering away it
would be like
the haunting of of andy's man
or something like andy's house
yeah i mean this is intriguing on two
levels the first one i i have a question
about because
is it that they feed off the children's
joy and they like suck it out of them so
like
or is it just that like by bringing the
children joy they get life force because
that seems the only way to do it they
can't just like
torture them like child's play yeah
because they would never want to play
with them right so like how can you get
joy out of it i feel like yeah as
a host symbiote scenario that that's
pretty the potential there would be
pretty short lived and then
they would die and then the kids lives
would get better as they play with the
corpses
so i guess that's pretty disturbing in
and of itself toys of our lives
that's always our life although i do
like the idea of that from the toys
perspective the toys do have just
finite lifespans and then once they're
dead
they are just there's like oh i don't
know slinky well that's actually he is
dead so i'm not going to use that
example rest in peace jim varney
uh but you know uh yeah like if one of
the toys were to
shuffle off in the toy story realm and
they're just playing with like the
hollow husk of a toy
yes or like how do the toys uh feel and
understand the idea that they are mass
produced and there are many of them
like there are a bunch of me that look
just like me
i this podcast today is also a toy story
also
probing the existential implications of
toy story
discuss solve for x before we move on to
the next super chat i do want to shout
out
aaron mitchell's comment really quick uh
that says batman v superman
versus resident evil uh
resident evil like zombies um i would
have loved
para zombies you know in batman v
superman how we were all upset
yes how remember in batman v superman
how we were all absolutely
right back to the super chest a bit but
remember batman's superman we're all set
about seeing
the you know like uh wonder woman teams
up to make doomsday and that's how it's
going to pretty much go to the finale
yeah yeah yeah
i would love that was all just a giant
cgi marketing mislead and then you watch
the actual movie and it's a
[ __ ] bunch of zombies zombie uprising
that's the net that was supposed to be
the next movie
you know that's what they're they're
looking at
yeah dude just laser then it's over
well they're dead anyway and they just
want to eat up they're dead
yeah if these repair demons this would
be a lot harder
thank god they were only zombies but i
took care of it all by myself standing
here
i didn't even have to fly this is kind
of really cool to
realize superman could just laser them
and it would probably be like the least
morally difficult challenge in all those
movies for him
sarah campbell what's up dear what a
dude she's saying
weekend at bernie's dude i like it
because think
if you just made it so that they have to
if you really made it a real-time movie
where they can't get discovered having
this dead guy's body with them but they
need it and they need to move around
with it
that could work well i mean yeah if it's
actually uh like trying to give off a
smell it feels cold
you can have it where you can make it
suspenseful yeah
you could make it really tension filled
you could take one of those scenes out
of
a few movies that do that where it's
like somebody's dead in the passenger
seat but they try to play it off like
they're just drunk
but a whole movie of them yeah basically
um okay there's actually there's a
really funny snl sketch that basically
it doesn't go full horror but it just
like they get discovered for what's
happening immediately and it takes
like real repercussions john keep
passing my phone for a second
i want to see if olivia's around of
course because i have to have her talk
about this next one there you go yeah
okay no wait no she's busy all right
so so so e.t
uh from carl tron front
carl
okay okay e.t
the extraterrestrial my girlfriend
olivia
refuses to watch t
and she is the toughest girl i know
toughest
person i know man woman whatever you
identify as
toughest but
e.t for some reason has just
freaked her out since she was a little
girl
and so she's never seen it hey man she
thinks he's a pedophile
no she's not she's
and i think e.t is just a terrifying
person like
there's he is creepy to look at i mean
think about it et is [ __ ] disgusting
to look at when you first see him
yeah he's supposed to be kind of
off-putting you're not going to see him
and be like
like he's kind of creepy looking yeah he
looks like something went wrong and then
he grows on you after a while you know
sweet but there's something about a skin
that looks like human it looks like it
looks like uh like a melted it looks
like a human epidermis you know
yeah yeah so it's gross
yeah just hone in on that first
impression yeah for 90 minutes
and it's all about kids going away
don't touch me and then from the other
side and then
the b plot then is also a story of
psychological anguish as et
just can't connect to anybody despite
the best of intentions
uh scott pilgrim horror that would be a
good one shooting i see
that is a good one highlander horror
also agree
tariq allen thanks for being here dude
dude
vampire as a kid is that the jonathan
nice movie
jonathan price jonathan bryce is a
little kid
i can't imagine jonathan price is
looking jonathan lip nicky
yeah yeah lip nicki all right
uh tariq oh hi guys all right we're
in ryder's room right now hi guys here's
what i'm thinking
pulp fiction and american beauty what do
you think
make those horror pitch it to me okay
oh american beauties uh has subtly
really creepy [ __ ] throughout all you
got to do is like
push up some tones and then you got a
horror movie right there that's a very
human horror
i mean with kevin's just the kevin
spacey storyline is you cast kevin
spacey and make it now
yeah then it's a horror movie
um and then uh pulp fiction it's all
from the point of view of the [ __ ]
yeah if you did like a [ __ ] standalone
movie [ __ ] origins
yeah for origins poor zed
or the tv zed team actually i wouldn't
want to say that'd be disturbing
i don't want to see that you know what
they do just alone in pulp fiction i
don't want to see what led them down to
that path never mind
it would be a horror movie but i don't
want to see the world we already have
like henry portrait of a serial killer
we don't need to do
more of that i quickly took that back
once i realized where that origin was
headed towards but clearly if you want
to make a splash that's the one you
green light uh and then going off that
et con from earlier raka diaz saying my
brother used to own an e.t
life-size doll so i threw it down the
laundry shoot every time i saw it
because of how terrifying it was
say sorry and t1 is standing up to some
animated adaptation of batman vampire
ooh batman v dracula dude i want to see
a live-action batman who laughs
i really really really do i could see my
zed's
my zed spin-off is not going the way
people want it to go
um zed's dead baby and cinema gorilla
american beauty another spielberg
dreamworks crew weird thing yes it is
oh that's right absolutely and alan ball
the creator at least show creator of
true blood
all right and then just making sure here
give us one sec guys
one that's all we ask
and it's done now oh i like the uh
eyeballs and the balloon
jane doe that's cool is that an it
reference or just
uh something spookums ah
let's see here mr beast butt
in horror sausage party the food eat the
people when they take them
while we're on the i'm refreshing this
um i saw this movie last night
that was really great uh the trial of
chicago the trial of chicago seven as a
horror movie
uh the trial of chicago seven highly
recommended it's a wonderful i've been
watching more netflix movies now than
ever
and it's actually a really uh it's it
was really great
really loved it aaron sorkin aaron
sorkin
sasha baron cohen steals the show and
yaya abdul mateen
[ __ ] great whoo he should act
he should ask he should act he should do
a movie once in a while
what the [ __ ] is he doing with his life
get out there he is
seeing him there's so many things he's
created why isn't he in more movies
he is in so many things now isn't he
yeah he's in
so many things zed and the [ __ ] spin-off
directed by rob zombie i'm about it
i'm about to daniel condren make arnold
richards great train they should bring
terminator back to being a horror movie
and then you might get some seats in the
theater again when the theaters open up
again i feel like that's the biggest
mistake they've made
or one actually no it's one of the many
mistakes they've made is to
alleviate the horror elements out of the
later installments
although i'll give one thing i will give
salvation is that there are a couple
moments in there that are genuinely
unsettlingly creepy
uh [ __ ] salvation [ __ ] it right in the
face uh
i don't like that movie at all can never
do it
in the ears what's this peter when
they're shouting out batman who laughs
would be
awesome horror yes i like it i want it i
want it i want it i want it
okay uh and then yeah topdog 721 an
actual horror resident evil movie
i wanna i know we got a lot of crap on
that monster hunter video
here's how i know i read all the likes
and dislikes i haven't read a single
comment from that video
um so or am i read like the first few
that came in
but i didn't read any hate comments but
i i know because i'm like guys
this guy did resident evil what [ __ ]
everyone so excited about this movie
well and from what i gather from looking
a little closer at the game
it doesn't it's not like about the
military and getting trips
it's like prehistoric and stuff really
yeah i told you it's not i
was like i bet i bet this is not
accurate to say it looks like it's it
looked to me like the stereotype of what
you would do to like
make a video game accessible to now
instead of just making the thing that it
was
you know that made people like it
tristan just said every
like tristan just said spider-man but
like the fly
body horror there's there is a storyline
where he grows
he grows six arms dude like a man that's
[ __ ]
disturbing just you know chill in a
kid's show it's disturbing to look at
there dude i want
david lynch's man spider i know david
we're your number number david yeah
let's get all the david's david lynch
david cronenberg and david fincher
david sandberg david sandberg and david
f
david henry and david henry director of
this is the year
david covney david duchovny he's
directed episodes of maybe
californication or stratharin maybe
yeah who knows jesus
john oh see judas thundersteel didn't
like the monster
hunter trailer so we're okay we're okay
as long as judas didn't like it yeah
at two tanks but judas don't like we
don't like
we don't like all right so what we got
eric horseman what's up buddy
eric not sure if anyone's said this yet
but weekend at bernie's as a zombie
horror funny
that's how you do it they don't expect
him to wake up
yes that's how you do it yes that's
great because we just rift on
how you could do like a refined scare
like suspenseful version weekend at
bernie said if you want to make a [ __ ]
oh my god i don't realize he's actually
becoming a part way through they think
it's working and then they realize it's
working a little too well
and that's how the outbreak starts
where'd you leave him i didn't leave him
i thought what are you talking about
somebody take him and then
at first they're like did somebody swipe
our dead bodies and they start becoming
more
like other people start becoming zombies
yes
and they're all wearing a frumpy hat and
sunglasses that's funny man
i love that one i'm wetting that this
no sorry no we have a mist thing on
because it gets really hot in here
yeah we're just raising the humidity but
it doesn't feel like it's got a wet
i love that sweater i really love that i
am a buddha
i'm a on what you call a [ __ ]
buddha stop
it my mom will shoot whole movie dude
all right well who do we got here oh
that's why
all right alan smithy what's up dudes
thanks alice smithy hell's yeah let's do
a bug's life
but with more insectoid horror one
character gets caught by a
spider wrapped up and sucked dry various
bugs will get crushed under people's
shoes heimlich the caterpillar gets his
abdomen
stuffed with wasp eggs
is there more here okay no there's
another one he has all right
oh boy that would be horrifying if you
because
i remember as a kid watching a bug's
life whenever they cut to the
grasshoppers
grasshoppers scared me they were
terrifying they're pretty in the finale
when it's like [ __ ] raining
yeah and you got hopper is like
ready to kill them and like i could
crush your head
that's scary yeah yeah when he's got his
head under your foot
yeah and you can imagine it because
you've crushed a bug
you've got that part of our stream for
secret horror movie secret horror movies
really movies that are secretly horror
movies true because i mean in that
i don't know what the true life you know
interaction between ants and
grasshoppers is but
truly like a big yeah let's make it as
realistic as possible a bigger more
predatory
you know insect than you like with all
the control and power that is a horror
movie let's really study how insects
the relationships are there's some nasty
things from our research we've never
seen a caterpillar a ladybug
an ant team up together to fight
grasshoppers we cannot make this movie
i i i guess i was a little office
i guess i was a little i don't know what
i did that's what i did
i did something wrong but but but alan
smithy's got
even more ideas let's make all the
beethoven movies into cujo movies
okay beethoven gets bitten by a bat
becomes rabid and terrorizes charles
grodin
bonnie hunt and the kids trapping them
in the house and taking them one
taking them out one by one but it can
start as a cute
family movie what are beethoven movies
beethoven is that big
uh he's a saint bernard dog and you know
it's one of those movies where like the
family gets a dog and he the dog causes
all kinds of hijinks but the kids are
really endeared to the dog but then the
family's like i think we got to get so
it's like a genre
well they just made some money like
beethoven was a was a franchise yeah
it's a franchise of dog
surprises yeah it's it's like airbud but
with no sports
uh yeah not familiar with that one
airbud could be a horror movie you know
like what if you learn to
do other things what if eric budd got
tired airbud gets his whole
bald buds together and murders everyone
yeah instead of learning how to shoot
balls they learn how to throw
knives and axes you love these old 90s
microphones vic i just happen to catch
your comment right now
uh yeah we do man i mean other people
are more professional
we actually have this stand here arm
thingy
put the mic on one of them on we just
need another one
but i don't know i feel a little bit uh
limited you know this feels very
very uh old school it feels holding a
microphone
and i feel like it does add a certain
level of like well okay i'm occupied by
at least
one thing to sort of be a ground wire
for the energy and normally i
uh i'm like moving around standing and
[ __ ] yeah i eventually do that pretty
early
on the stream but today uh i've kind of
just been sitting here i don't want to
move from this chair
i'm really comfortable in this chair
right okay we can get some like
microphone arm things that like latch
onto the sides of the desk and just like
wheel them into our moods
by the way hashtag hispanic heritage
month heritage
here it is here the third month
hashtag hispanic heritage month
historic heritage month if you're
celebrating
sound off in the comments scream queen
and neesa
scream queen anisa let's hear your best
scream
yeah let's scream really loudly into the
mics
no just as high pitched as possible just
denise and let's see
if it doesn't bother anyone especially
those of you in headphones
let's see how much they appreciate it
you can just lower the volume later
heck you can roller it right now if you
think about it 50 first dates is already
a horror movie
where a guy doggedly stalks a woman you
see this is what i mean
cancel culture allows no room for
romance
hey there's a thin line between romance
and creepiness and that thin line is
literally
i kind of like you
that's it you can get away with a lot of
kind of creepy on i kind of like you
it's already a horror movie where a guy
doggedly stalks a
woman incapable of remembering anything
about him
he orchestrates an endless string of
creepy meat cutes and manipulates her
into falling for him oh my god
i mean she he doesn't just manipulate
her into falling for him
he manipulates her every single single
day i would serve an 18 year old son in
harvard now
[Laughter]
you went to the meeting every morning
this video
i make you watch gets longer and longer
and longer
and i am spending every day editing and
exporting this new video for you
our family members have mostly died
this has been going on for so many years
they
did actually on drew barrymore's youtube
channel
they did a like reunion i don't know if
it's a youtube channel or actual talk
show she has
but she has a channel for it uh account
for it on youtube
they did a a bit a skit of like adam
sandler and drew barrymore and like
she got into the makeup of her uh of
like an updated one and they're making
fun of like how things could have gone
wrong i'm like you guys could have gone
way crazier with this
oh this this is literally impossible
you cannot pull this off plus you know
if he got tired of it he could take a
break for a day and have rob schneider
do it and there would probably never be
any difference be
to be told from that um but yeah i would
say um
i would say yeah no i agree with you it
already is a horror movie
i mean it's it's it's creepy in like
context you just got to tell people what
this if i were to tell
someone what this every day he visits
this woman trying to get her to fall in
love with him
and he keeps finding out more and more
information about her
and she does like just like the dates
part you know
is this on the dates part yeah yeah yeah
that's just creepy
oh goodness like yeah my mind is really
gonna manipulate every day he could do
something
terrible yeah he could he could pin a
crime on her he could do the worst
he could like yell at her and call her
the worst names
ever he could misbehave to the umpteenth
degree and
then the next day leave it out never
talk about it
no one would ever know this is it's this
personal human playground
of the mind right there and we know adam
sandler has a temper
he he does um reportedly
he keeps seeing jeremy stop copying me a
dog's what did jeremy say a dog's
purpose where he possibly stops
copying me and i'm going to read
jeremy's comment
dog's purpose or he possesses other dogs
coming the owners until he is finally
back with the original owner
oh hey not bad man oh golly
all right damn i had uh something popped
into my mind but now it's gone
per usual per yeah everything i say is
gone from my mind
forrest gump alan smithy alan smith
thank you for scum
john you take this one take it away john
forest
the gump is a serial killer he gets a
taste of murder after killing jenny's
horrible father
he secretly follows jenny killing the
men in her life as they wrong her
life is like a box of chocolates
looks like your box is empty
that that clinched it for me that's why
he's named alan smithy
that's you're not gonna put your name on
that was the original pitch for forrest
gump
they were looking for writers you know i
i want this movie
they're like we'll buy it from you but
we're not going with it this would be
perfect because you could do it like
maniac but you could have it where like
the person he loves is not just the only
bright spot in his life
it's literally the motivation for all
these people that he's killing yeah it's
to protect this person that he loves
all right and in pov first person flev
dorin
hmm thank you thank you flev one of our
patrons too thank you
much
most disney classics can easily be
horrors or darker grims brother films
and some of them are inspired by their
work
did you know the original ending for the
fox and the hound the hound kills the
fox
and then the owner of the hound is i
think is like
all right no use for you anymore and
then just shoots the dog
i thought you were that's horrible i
think
they should remake fox and the hound
like the lion it's on my list
do the live action version of fox and
the hound like the disney live action
and do it completely faithfully
until that moment so the
whole 90 minutes is like and it becomes
god disease [ __ ] do something
creative do
something unique why the [ __ ] do you
just do these shot for shot
remix and then bam jesus christ what the
i thought you were going to say that the
the they made the
hound eat the fox or something like that
oh no no that's
that's bad john what i'm talking about
it's possible pg content yes
this is for kids remember i'm trying to
hit that as shown in
john is hispanic he's celebrating
hispanic heritage much
i have played at he's 45 years old on
yeah
i was born in juarez scream queen and
nisa
onward is technically if you think about
it
going into the horror realm was it just
me or did it also kind of remind you of
supernatural with sam and dean looking
to track
uh looking trying to bring their dad
back oh yeah
dude the winchester boys actually onward
in some ways is a slight
seems like you could be like it's it's
inspired by supernatural mm-hmm
brothers trying to get their father back
in a world where all the magical
creatures exist
yeah yeah making deals with magical
realms in order to do so you could do
onward scary you could even do that live
action
onward is one you can make live action
just it would be expensive as [ __ ] and
then you'd
can practical affects everyone it's not
that you practical effects everyone or
no one
uh yeah exactly well you know gone are
the tastes
of like yeah slightly made-up extras
uh my name is name uh he's saying who
are these people i just searched live
right now
well i'm akkason and i'm tyrone magnus
nice to meet you
thanks for being here my name is name
glad to see you here
and we're going to react to some captain
react to some cat that's what
aukasan does that's what
tyrone yeah paul's cat videos
good mythical morning corner
um okay
all right eric was here eric horseman
thanks buddy thank you for such a big
one too thomas the tank engine
is a killer train because he is creepy
looking as [ __ ]
lol bradley oh i gotta watch your video
bradley just made a video about
about the creepiness of the the newly
redesigned thomases or something like
that what's something about thomas
john i'm butchering type in new scary
thomas
there's no not on youtube yeah or is
this something uh
scary thomas yeah yeah we got it we got
it
okay that can't be that can't be real
all right
thomas the tank engine go to go to that
one and then and then i'll type in 2020
on top of it
okay go for it
okay does he look different a day out
with thomas is that what it is
usa calendar 22. oh my god his eyes are
are really popular this guy
is that the one is that the one we're
talking about his eyes are super popping
there is like a pervy thing about him he
does look overly
pleased yeah he looks a little too
pleased i'm gonna ram some trains today
usually the caboose goes on the back but
not tonight
hey guys um
actually you know i would love to see
eric horseman i would love to see a
thomas
i know i know this would be perfect
since you're such a big blind manor fan
of mike flanagan
thomas the tank engine he's he's uh he's
on the
he's on the railroad right and then
suddenly he runs out of gas
oh no and he's stranded oh no you see
thomas was trying to escape from
something but we don't know
his his dark past don't know what yeah
and then he's suddenly confronted
by other members of his family ghosts
and and you start learning like what led
him down this railroad
these tracks it's like it's like
gerald's game
look at those look damn
[Music]
thomas creepy oh
hank you suck hank all right
well we should have shown his comment
now we don't know why a guy named hank
came here to say you guys suck and then
uh can i unhide it no it's okay
he's got nothing else better to do with
his time because he's a [ __ ] loser
so he's like i was gonna go here i'm
going to pin the message now
um so there you go hank's pinned he
can't find anything else to
do productively so he uh conforms here
that's the way that goes with those kind
of people you know all righty
levy deep [ __ ]
no it's all right he wins uh uh hank
wright wins he's the pink comment
flev doran it's been fun gotta do that
sleep thing i talked about earlier stay
safe guys thank you flef thanks for
being here buddy hey look at that
pearl harbor has a horror movie sweet
nan nan in here hello sweet nan named
happy friday y'all coming in late and
it's a weird one but i would pay to see
harold
cooper oh that's great that's great
i hate to see harold kumar in a haunted
house
or demon possession horror that is
perfect
yes i should do one where they swap
bodies but you could do one
in a haunted hotel a herald the kumar
horror adventure one would be perfect
yeah well they don't know if they're
tripping or if they're actually seeing
premonitions
and apparitions i mean they did
christmas they wanted to do like a
halloween one yeah man
they have a built-in excuse now to do
any holiday they want and halloween
would be perfect and the first one got
like
creepy at one point when they go to that
guy's house the pop and zits and [ __ ]
yeah that was like creepy and kind of it
was like unsettling right
so you could do like a full-blown horror
hall uh harold the kumar version right
harold and halloween
harold and kumar halloween scream queen
anisa hey hey
nanny mcv where she ends up murdering
the entire family and just moving on to
the next house afterwards
hello brandon welcome here i thought you
could do this as well with mary poppins
i think that could work nanny mcphee
where she
ends up murdering the entire family and
just moved on to the next house
afterwards
yeah oh so okay she poses herself as
like a
like this trustworthy nanny yeah yeah
but instead she's just a murderous
i actually really like that yeah yeah it
could work they like take her in
at first they're like no she's a little
strange but whatever she's british
but then the last family is the one that
figures out that she's probably a killer
so the kids become the heroes yeah they
turn out
the dad's like you kids are crazy
she's a nanny take takes yeah stop
beating up on your nice caring nanny
we pay her good money which is nothing
cause she's asked for nothing
[Laughter]
but man no she would have no ulterior
motive here
no she just does a set of the kindness
of her heart that's right
money is no good where she's wrong john
is dating grace right oh no that wasn't
supposed to get out
tell cosmic culture it'll be an article
about it soon yeah break it to cosmic
wonder
and he'll hear about it soon tell
emergency awesome yeah
what's up everyone grace we're here
today to talk about how this
news report recently came out that real
rejects
john humphrey is actually in a secret
relationship with beyond the trailers
grace randolph
here's the top 10 what the [ __ ] moments
what the [ __ ] number 10.
great all right i guess we'll talk about
that
grace will you marry me wow
uh mortal kombat horror i think the new
one will be having a little bit of that
oh definitely with all the horror
characters they're adding in
all right what time are we at we are at
6 30 6 00.
the clock will wrap up soon guys and
we've got 6 13
on the stream lab just now but let's see
where we are
okay how oh whoa okay we're not too
behind then i don't think so not not on
the stream
just refreshing on super chats but not
the stream lamps
john don't fall behind on the comments
handle it while i refresh everything
talk to the people all righty
ooh sweeney todd mixed with 50 shades i
actually think would make that much more
interesting
i would love to see thomas the tank
engine as a ghost train
or as like a murder have have a poirot
murder mystery with kenneth branagh
on board thomas the tankage and like do
a mashup there
um why are wreckadillo why are you why
are you explaining who we are
who doesn't know because my name is my
name is is here
oh okay um okay no let us handle our
pitch for ourselves i appreciate you
stepping in recording
it it helps more when other people speak
for you yeah it does
uh this is dated to my love life with
grace randall we do
reactions then we do a lot of we do
commentary after the reactions we don't
just say subscribe right away we try to
bring a smile to your face at least once
a day every once in a while we'll do
like
random skits and sketches uh we do
reviews and
like this live stream is essentially our
podcast for today
and uh yeah you know we'll do like
discussions and whatever you know like
but that's just us so
i really do hope that since you stumbled
upon this stream today that you might
consider subscribing
your vote means a lot so get to that
ballot box
get to that ballot box work past your
vote we're closer than ever before in
the polls it's really complicated
all we need is a chance i feel like
people think that we're
we can stand out a little bit different
from other reactors from time to time uh
which i really appreciate
especially because of the commentary but
you know everyone as long as you stick
to your personality you do present a
unique edge so i feel like all reactors
can be unique in that way
but you know we like to do our thing one
of the only reactors that compete in the
movie trivia showdown
the reactor that so you know we got a
bit of a reputation
look at that oh yeah we mainly react
that's about it
i hope you're enjoying that bowl of
garlic because i'm jealous of you
okay john let me refresh this one more
time i'll do it i think we're good to go
young trip i've seen it before in the
chat but i also i'm seeing it now
mad max i feel like you could totally
there's tons of horror like it's already
kind of horrific in the way a lot of the
characters behave but there's got to be
some like really spooky
[ __ ] in that universe uh oh wait hold on
we got another legend wait trip what's
up everybody
you suck as well so i'm gonna pin your
comment to the top of the chat
that pin is yeah there you go yeah
there's oh stop joking he was joking
guys oh okay never mind hank wright's
staying then
john sorry too much you you're trying to
people please too much i didn't mean it
don't follow in my footsteps there is a
lot of naked greg on this channel jerry
garza
there is some pretty you there's one
where i'm pretty neat there's one where
you see my ass from a few years ago
uh-huh
and it's on my pubes
that video is age restricted i you know
that's a real shame it's a real crowd
that's one from like
you know youtube i'm not gonna complain
about it i'm not gonna fight you so that
young people can see myself
i think uh i think you judged wisely on
this one
oh richard bentley we suck the best and
and it's okay legend
you are you are a beautiful song sean
you're hurting my ego
oh dude cinema cinema gorilla loves us
and grace randolph and that's kind of
love gotta block anyone who's even
disagrees with us
yes we gotta anyone who disagrees with
our opinions
who has anything to say about the
channel itself my favorite skits are the
ones when i do a skit
and then people even if it's like a
little bit like a bit when i say like
a little bit bit like the black widow
one yesterday yeah that's a bit
that's a skit i mean there were people
especially when i posted on instagram
i was like damn soon as people don't
realize i didn't
like they think i actually just had a
camera recording
just set up ready to record i just i
just walk into this room at any given
moment 24
hours a day there's an omniscient
perspective
waiting for you just for wherever you
decide
you're gonna start addressing the
possibility of this yeah
that is that is an interesting thing
about that that's my favorite ones where
people get mad
that is a magical like when you forget
that this took
time to set up and that there had to
have been a shot prepared
why are you what did you get
unsubscribing anissa started i didn't
mean it look what you started anissa
cause you gave so much love to these
people don't worry i know there's
something coming up in the super chats
that i'm aware of and don't worry
you i'm gonna make your night with with
somebody you do some vocals
you did vibe of the stream now oh
i'm sorry guys i didn't mean to ruin the
stream this is the true horror
this is the horror rap what if this
stream turned into a psychological
plug this part of the mic use the button
beat you to beat you
and i forget that we're on a stream
because i have that
and then all i hear is a ring yeah yeah
yeah and then
john i completely forget we're live
streaming the whole time and then this
is from
from henceforth you never speak again
yes and and you're like you know all
your vital signs work
this is when she leaves the stream all
right this is done
yeah i'm finished greg saw oh thanks
kevin shepard
yeah greg saw one one day we'll do
greg's saw two
uh let's see greg was great thank you
brother you've seen it you know
our most uh the sketches have worked our
ass the ones that took the hardest
people haven't seen
i know end game was the hardest one to
put together
um the the we never talk about the
sketches
was the hardest one we put together
in terms of one for a trailer reaction
like mission impossible we did shoot
that in like a couple hours yeah yeah
two to three hours it took like to shoot
and took a while to edit
that one was very spatially spread out
but we got a lot of stuff pretty well
but the end game one was like i had to
like contact all those [ __ ] people
and then coordinate i had to shoot a
video to be like here's how you do it
all right so it was uh it was it was
that was a complicated one
um but yeah gosh all right feels like
forever ago now
i know now the skits are like yelling at
warren from cosmic wonder about venom or
the presidential debate
yeah yeah it's like yelling but then
though i mean i'm pretty proud of the
one i did about jesus coming to the mcu
that
worked my ass off on that it was a good
af and a nice foray into the talking to
myself format
uh what's up erica welcome back and also
thank you for the uh
the cancellation party guys i really
appreciate you celebrating my overness
grant wilson glad to have you here buddy
oh thanks eric i'm glad not to be over
oh and also chase thank you for the
joker sketch love
oh thank you yeah john killed it on that
joker makeup
um okay so here we go oh no we did this
one we covered it
that's right we made sure to cover it
yes
uh what time is it all right appreciate
everyone to send in super
chats and for the stream labs too but at
the
i think we're gonna say at this point we
should probably not have any more new
ones come in because we would like to
wrap up
uh in about a hopefully a half hour but
knowing our style let's see what happens
guys
see how it goes uh while we got energy
i don't want to just end on the mower
like i'm exhausted now yeah
i realized why we're tired why why we
would tend to be tired
uh after the two after hour and a half
two hour mark it's because other
channels to do it that's usually the
first thing they're doing that day or
the only thing they're going to be doing
that day oh yeah
we usually do it after a full week and
then a day's work and
then go into here yeah this is this is
literally
the week that's what i realized is like
ah
we should kick off monday mornings nine
am what's up guys everyone's busy
no one's watching oh [ __ ] no one's here
but us
so sarah campbell give halloweentown a
cabin in the woods vibe
john take it away thank you that's right
you know
i used to love that movie growing up and
uh yeah if
you made it some sort of meta universe
that has these overlords that like
dictate its rules as to the nature of
other horror properties
that could be cool that's fun you know i
mean halloweentown
i guess i would be curious to see how it
would lend itself to a movie with as
much kind of like
hip edgeness as as that one has as you
have in the wood heads but uh yeah i
like it i'm for it
i'm supportive of this also thank you
cinema gorilla
uh the john humphrey is over after party
uh is gonna be great
matilda into a horror movie i feel would
be
easy you know i haven't seen matilda
dude it's great flick
danny devito directed it what's matilda
about matilda is about
a young girl with psychic powers
uh and it's sort of like a it's by roald
dahl who did
charlie the chocolate factory and the
witches and and uh james the giant peach
and
fantastic mr fox and all those stories
um
and yeah i mean like there's
she's got these psychic powers and
there's this like evil headmistress at
the school she goes to is like really
oppressive to the kids
and it's kind of you know about them
learning to be resilient in the face of
that and to break free also matilda's
family is really terrible
um it's raw doll writes books that have
very like
dark themes and i was letting john
explain the plot of matilda to kill the
time
yeah that's all good so uh you know but
yeah
all right because i feel like matilda as
a horror movie would become
like maybe kind of omenesque but with
just les satan
you know yeah john
thanks thanks oh trust me
i was listening the whole time it was
not just trying to give you something to
revamp
while i was trying to figure out how to
how to pin and repent
oh no you pinned bill waters comment i
totally absorbed everything you said
and the words you said were the best
this was important though guys are we of
matilda
are we gay comment below no i haven't
seen matilda drew
dude it's a good it's a great movie
shouts out tomorrow i could also name
some other movies i haven't seen
let's do it on the next let's do it and
just tell us the ending guys
next next stream it'll be movies that
greg hasn't seen
who's top you know i found of course
olivia's
we're just face down on the back yeah
dragons what are you gonna say i thought
of a dope trope again
that is a very horror movie specific
that drives me nuts and part of me is
like i should save it for the next dope
tropes but the other part of me is like
i don't know when that'll be and i don't
want to forget
and this is my side door what
advertisement for the
future dope tropes revivalist well i
hope
why don't you write down a word i'm
going to write down a word
that can jog the memory of what that
trope
is so hopefully you don't forget it
yes i'm gonna write down a
confusing code so that only i will know
oh lennon since you were the first one
to do
to do to do this comment oh duty i'm
going to replace it
you're the only one now who says that
who gets to have it i have seen the
green inferno matthias rain
uh it it it is it is kind of disturbing
and hard to watch in various ways there
are movies even more disturbing in the
same vein if you would like
dragon soldier is asking ooh hey guys
i hope i'm not too late into the stream
i would love to see a horror version of
the mask
like the original comment well yes
this is one of the first things we
talked about during the stream
but just as a refresher in case some
people have
shown up here a little bit late um
wow bill waters is now going to be
hidden john
dude it is a [ __ ] name but
unfortunately
it's the name of so i don't know
he's got to be hidden all right hide
this user
i'm gonna put you in timeout put your
ass in time
out um so yeah we would love to see a
version of the mess we would think jim
carrey could come back and make it a
full-blown horror comedy where he's gone
a little bit
maybe the mask has had some maybe he's
gone crazy and he's lost everything
cameron diaz doesn't want to be with him
anymore
dude now she's a prostitute at the coco
cabana or whatever the [ __ ] she worked
and then uh he's like a senile kooky old
man
and then the mask falls back into his
lap again
ooh yeah and then you know he goes on
another mad cap
yes i love kirby
stop giving in to the people i want to
please the peace
hey certain
everyone dies in it oh no that's not
true but it is an awesome movie all
right
i'm glad you agree with that all right
thank you dragon soldier appreciate that
mr vaju
what about bob with horror element he's
already kind of a horror
movie a psychopathic crazy patient that
stalks his doctor and follows him to his
vacation home than murdering everyone
honestly that's another one that could
just be a slight uptick in a certain
tone
like by the finale it's kind of creepy
you could do that with what about bob
that's one that you could like the way
how cable guys seem kind of scary
what about bob was right on the verge of
being that kind of dark vibe
yeah so you could have done that with
there dude that's what about bob
uh who's next appreciate that mr bashu
mr fajou
i love your name i like to say it anissa
any disney princess movie where they
never get a happy ending would that be a
horror movie or too much reality
both i think i mean yeah if you did like
pocahontas
her story she didn't like leave with jon
snow woman was kidnapped forced into
marriage
john john smith no john john um john
humphrey and pocahontas
john um uh john
[ __ ] john uh yeah so
yeah i would say that if you did
pocahontas would be way too realistic
and disturbing
little mermaid i think you could do a
little mermaid it would be tragic
yeah you could do a little mermaid why
the [ __ ] not yeah
i'm down but pocahontas plus you get i
mean they said a new world is the
realistic version like they didn't do a
lot of what really happened
yeah it's pretty brutal realistic by
comparison she
died a terrible death yeah so
yeah the pocahontas one is probably one
of the most misleading ones of them all
yeah that's historical fiction that's
just not like we're taking from a
fictional novel
and we're making it happier yeah yeah
yeah it's like we're gonna totally make
you think
this was actually a beautiful story when
really this was a
horrible horrible horrible thing that
happened to this one woman
yeah man that's how history works that's
how that's how we
that's how we spread the history this is
not a [ __ ] a niece is a gorgeous
beautiful woman i concur
all right ain't no [ __ ] here tariq
allen
la la land in a friday the 13th universe
what does that mean so you sing city of
stars but
under jesus i don't understand you gotta
dance away from jason
look what is the movie here you know
jason's angry at kids who don't
appreciate classic jazz
and so he's just killing a bunch of kids
who are playing crappy modern jazz
a bunch of kids come to the campsite
over the weekend to have a jazz festival
yeah
he kills them all well john you figured
it out there we go
jerry garza appreciate you saying that
too oh
oh ricotta's right yeah what about
beauty and the beast man oh thanks for
the scary emojis
look john someone was being a dick and
they got hidden on this channel
permanent
being a d so john to tell anisa
give her what she wants john can i
please
hear your southern accent to make my day
also a greg i would like to hear yours
as well since i don't think i ever have
my southern accent sounds a little bit
more like
like this hey anissa
pleasure to have you here on our channel
today
you're such a such an astounding woman
yeah the stars come out of your eyes
yeah they
holy my lordy i'm going to go masturbate
in the woods
bring your banjo with you
while picking my teeth with the strings
yes
i think and that is even better john's
my brother
for some reason he's the governor of the
town and all i do is
clean the bushes at night i'm just a
lonely landscape damn
i'm just a shrub trimmer i live in the
backwoods
he lives in the nice bird house and the
only thing i'm qualified to use is these
big old pruning shears
this is going to be the real rejects
southern gothic
yeah a little bit tiger king dude
christina
wants the marvel that sounds like the
pervert guy and the tiger king
yeah oh yeah a little bit together i'm
gonna never recover from this
financially
uh okay now let's change the pin comment
to something that just wouldn't make
sense for any new person jumping in here
uh let's go with this one
that way we can just uh here you guys
will like this new pinned comment
yes unless you guys are having a
conversation about something really
serious
that i did not pick up on i then i
should probably change that
i just like the idea of people popping
in the chat being like why is this the
pin
out of context pin comments
pinned out of context uh and then
christine
yeah christina christina oh wow i
haven't stood all stream and i got a
little lightheaded uh
i haven't stood all stream
marvel zombies movie yes absolutely a
marvel zombies movie
is one that we're all dying to see and i
think you could do that
on hulu yes at least
something like that you know i think
that would be a perfect one
go poke around youtube and uh a guy
named i know named scotty
fields made a marvel zombies short film
where he made all like the practical
effects
and stuff and he shot it on his own so
it's a little like that's how you do
your punisher kills the marvel universe
is they all become
zombies and the only one left standing
is frank
castle yes oh dude who better to take
out a universe of zombies
but then what kind like do those super
zombies have any remnants of their power
no okay good then this is just shooting
people
he's gonna be a all right i am really
happy about this i want to see it
i want it green lit get thomas jane back
all right here we go i hope the punisher
gets to take advantage of the multiverse
so that we can have thomas jane
and john bernthal and ray stevenson
so who's this anissa
do you all remember the 2000
the little vampire uh and if so did you
all appreciate it i feel it's so
underappreciated probably as much as
monster squad i feel like monsters
i don't remember the little vampire that
well i think i've only seen a commercial
for it
i think i've only seen yeah commercial
on the video cover of the box
so i think it's maybe more under under
watched or underrated than the monster
squad yeah
because uh because like 90s kids got it
you know but you might have missed it
like us
uh i want to highlight bill waters
comment in here uh on the regular
live stream oh good that's saying why
y'all are a bunch of chicks
i must can't take a joke huh here's what
i got to say to that
i would say chicks
are probably way way
stronger at taking an insult over the
internet
or a joke a mean joke than
any guy i know do you know what messages
woman get what
chicks get it's not the default setting
for us
i just think that if you're gonna say
you guys are behaving like chicks can't
take a joke i'm like well i think
i think women probably take jokes way
better than guys doing i think
you're simply accusing us of not being
able to handle a joke very well which is
a possibility for annie
but i would say i wouldn't put chicks in
that category
also uh you know keep in mind that the
written
format with absolutely no punctuations
doth not carry
tonality and intention very well i don't
know which one he's referring to by the
way
yeah i don't know what your joke was i
don't know i blocked as of a joke
i don't know what they're talking about
if you just dropped in your channel
sucks as a joke
with no punctuations it's not going to
read the way yeah if you're spamming it
i'm just going to
yeah i'm just going to assume that you
have no good will or if you spam in
general yeah
although spam the food underrated spam
is great it's delicious
i haven't had it in years oh dude peter
pacheco
the cat in the hat also anissa my
girlfriend and i
are going to watch monster squad this
week also did you watch the two links i
sent you about 2020
oh well did you john did you did you
i'm posting this on you did you haven't
seen the links
what the hell john why didn't you watch
the two links you son of a [ __ ]
you were supposed to have watched it i
am a bad guy you're behaving like a
bunch of
this just to victimize you because i
don't like you
at all i'm just kidding peter uh i'm
still
resending i'm going to watch the links
to john's dna to watch the list
on twitter and instagram facebook
as soon as i do that as soon as i learn
portuguese accent
for you yeah all for you all for you
pacheco that's a friend's fernand
girls do get it done thank you
wreckadillo unhide that comment
all right here we go
what are you reading john rereading did
we figure out right here
girls do get it done show that comment
girls do get it done hell yeah
the boys the boys we all know what the
reference of the boys
oh all right so what's going on grace
randolph does get a lot of hate cinema
gorilla that's absolutely true
but she's more successful than almost
everyone that hates her yeah
maybe the filmmaker with that they have
given her a crap but
you know but she doesn't don't listen to
hate who was a [ __ ] always a [ __ ]
i don't think that he's talking about us
john i don't know
i mean i'm reading some of the comments
here oh okay
why are you letting that show that's not
about us oh i don't know
don't hide it now now you're gonna look
like a [ __ ] you're gonna look like a
bunch of chicks
in my uh in my ever
ever expanding goal to not overthink
things
i am going to heed your advice
yeah [ __ ] who is he who's who's he
talking about that's what we got i think
he's talking about anissa if he's
talking about anissa
then there's there's a fight's broken
out because i think this is not
anissa is an angel anisa is not a [ __ ]
is
one of our saviors yeah man did you did
she maybe not understand the joke that
nobody understood was a joke
i believe in a democracy
if bill is upsetting too many people
you know who faced bill maybe
maybe we just got to get rid of him oh
maybe we just gotta
hide this user on the channel uh oh
because it's kind of fun
just be like huh usually we're just like
hide he's annoying and people in the
chat
but to call him out and then to ban him
from the comments
hey diabolique that actually sounds fun
that does you know i think we're gonna
do it how many likes do we have
as soon as we why didn't we get to 200
likes
just do it get rid of it all right bill
winters here we go
where's guys being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
get ready
sucking dees the [ __ ] not in a
good way bill waters
is gone going after the people in an
unfair way
no it's mean bill waters this is how we
moderate
here we go guys it got stuck i didn't be
able to stop being a dick
we control it we can get rid of everyone
i always find it so funny when people
are because we have people who give us
[ __ ] sometimes
and we're just like all right fine you
know like but sometimes we just let it
happen
yeah i don't get when people are like
you know [ __ ] called out tyrod or
called out grace
on this [ __ ] that she said did it in a
real nasty way
and she blocked me what a [ __ ] like
well dude
you're being [ __ ] up consider for a
mere
moment if somebody in a pleasant
scenario just came at you with that
would you not be maybe a little
redirected bill was the imposter
got him out of here
floating out into hyperspace all right
maybe
maybe he'll buy some angry uh birds
cameos from
yes and the canon that was scary sorry
peter pacheco didn't honor that enough
was scary yes that that concept in it
itself can be terrifying and the mike
myers one
was easy to slice him into these like
horror fanfic videos like
uh it but it's cat in the hat you know
like something that was easy to do
cat in the it anise is saying also want
to let everyone know it's hispanic
heritage month
i'm very proud of where i come from even
if the president wants to kick
out all of us but we are strong he won't
break us dude let's not
get all about religion okay
yeah let's not talk about we're we're
free to worship trump if we want
all right all right separation of church
and state except for when
it's catholicism you should be proud of
nesa
olivia's also hispanic so [ __ ] yeah yeah
hispanic heritage munch baby
[Music]
no but seriously uh hell yeah hell yeah
i'm
i'm very happy that we can at least be a
tangential part of hispanic heritage
month dude
uh uh hispanic heritage i've i've grown
up
around the latino people yeah i've i've
grown up here i grew up in the valley
you know how many
hispanic friends we've had our whole
lives oh dude
oh dude yeah generations
love the hispanic love the hispanic
people all hispanic people are the best
the best way to build goodwill with any
community is just to single them out as
an ethnic group and say that you like
them
and also making sure we don't lump
hispanics i like the same category
well there you go thank you for
acknowledging that
car what does it say boris karloff kauff
tron
cow trot back to the future but marty is
more like biff
ha ha where are you what does that mean
swap out
for biff and then you so it's back to
the future too
okay except it would be worse if if biff
actually just got i mean if you wanted
to make back to the future horror movie
just have him go all the way with his
mom like he's tempted by it
and he's like man you know but [ __ ]
my mom from 20 years ago looks so
different and
hot i'm attracted to her now i'm
realizing my girlfriend jennifer
kind of looks like her [ __ ] i've always
been attracted to my mom
should i do this i think i'm gonna do it
and then
the twist ending is the marty mcfly that
the whole
time was his own dad it was never george
mcfly never about pushing george mcfly
to oh wow think about that wow
and we todd but we can't take a joke
that should be directed by todd's salons
it would work that would be a tough
tell me you wouldn't watch that back to
the future movie hey
back to back from calf
hey hey for some reason we're all
shouting out hispanics
i don't know michael b's comment said
girlfriend is hispanic
and with the emoji and it's i had a
choice to show or hide this comment
maybe maybe we must have blocked the
word hispanic down the road
only when a white guy says it maybe yeah
youtube was super actually showed up in
this chat the whole time if a white guy
is using any racial terminology
that could be oh my god might not be
good here new community guidelines
infused here
oh boy cartron's also saying tarzan
thoughts
oh yeah if you just made him instead of
him being like oh you know
man who's wrong oh you know i'm tazing
i feel like this is another one where
the original story is much darker anyway
but yeah if you just had him
come up really as like a just a deranged
feral creature man what you do is you
throw tarzan into therapy that's what
you would pull him out of the jungle
throw him into therapy and then he
overtakes
london he overtakes london he just
climbs up a building
is it cultural appropriation if you're
white and dating hispanic
yes 100 no mark my words yes it is
absolutely and then uh mike is only
allowed to take
mike how to train your chase gardner how
to train your dragon live
action horror game of thrones is what
it's called
game of thrones bye richard bentley see
ya buddy
dude it's it's it's the game of thrones
prequel right there it's gonna be the
targaryen uh show but yeah love who you
love man
yeah just love who you love love
everyone
but especially who you love i saw a
great video going around
about heath ledger talking about
homosexuality
promoting brokeback mountain it was
beautiful watch it
anyway how to train your dragon live
action horror
i mean yeah i mean just you could do
literally that but
just change the tones around and then
bam there you go yeah i mean they are
pretty scary he loses a leg
you know like the the the the dragons
they could burn people up he's
he's impotent
he's impotent
what does that mean i don't know where's
the nieces
who's impotent i don't know we gotta
find out i was saying
[ __ ] the how to train a dragon how to
turn your dragon
oh no it's toothless oh toothless no no
the [ __ ] guy what's the guy's name
harry j barrish jay bird's character oh
hiccup
hiccup hiccup yeah yeah all right let me
make sure we're all caught up here let's
make sure
we got a cup we got i think maybe one
more in the uh
no no we got one or two in this stream
this is the last one of the
of the super chats thank you so much
everybody today thank you good night
legend
good night love you buddy
no dude it's all good it's all good you
handled that situation
well because clearly it became clear you
weren't a hater very fast so thank you
deontay deonte my friend
tongue punch fart box where's anisa
someone find me a nissa do you want to
check my messages here
dionte
oh nisa i i blocked
uh yeah no i got her okay i sent her a
message
oh is she okay yo i got it i got it guys
don't worry
all right i feel like if you change the
rating
on holes it becomes a thriller
i think you can make finding nemo a
horror too but not sure
how well well what you do is i think
i think what you do nemo gets picked up
at a fish restaurant
if you get rid of um if you get rid of
marlin
he dies and then you get it's dory
having to find nemo
and having to work with that amnesia
element then it can be
very scary and then you can watch like
the other more vicious
animals in the water to have some brutal
kills
oh dude way more angler fish yeah and
holes yes
in its dna is a thriller stanley and
um so is uh passion of the christ to the
certain extent i wonder if you make fun
of passion of the christ
is that making fun of christ or is that
just making fun of the movie
oh how what's the mantle yes
it's both what's this is my you might
get you get toy story i get
mel gibson related topics to go on side
tangents here those are our two topics
yeah
any real rejects like uh like an easter
egg guide will feature those
you can have human deaths into finding
nemo horror version too you know
oh oh bill's back bill's back bob is
bill back as bob as bob waters bill
is bill waters bob waters this guy
doesn't have much of a life right now
i don't know that's too bad these people
who
do nothing with their lives nothing with
their lives but
hatred to spread no they're happy in
their personal lives
all right there we go and uh what's
going on here
what isn't going on here and oh my god
john you
you said it i forgot to mention i'm so
sorry john where'd it go right there
streams
there it is all right streamlabs
is this is this refreshed yes
refresh it one more all right the last
few here we go
uh no refresh it once more actually
sorry about that sure sure
got the live right there
just making sure just making sure
everything's cool over there
now whenever a silence passes i'm like
oh goodness
i need to be filling it i need to be
filling the silence
anissa everyone's got your back got the
[ __ ] back
everyone's got her back gotcha gotcho
gotcha
back okay
worked right uh yeah so yeah
yeah okay here we go so so
you missed the spider-man you missed the
news you're so calm right so quiet
i know all right things breaking out in
the chat
just brings the mood to a nooch all
right here we go
eric horseman another crazy one thank
you buddy
pretty woman woman killer hooker takes
revenge on all the shop
[ __ ] who wouldn't assist her and
treat her like trash and then marries
richard gear goes all black widow on him
and she gets all his money
i like it that's like that's a great one
i want it
that's a great especially if you make
richard gere kind of [ __ ] up
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's like right now
he's
like controlling yeah and he's really
manipulative and gaslighty
what's a hooker always a hooker yeah
it's just like just [ __ ] up chit
just like gets a revenge or
gender flip it it's a male gigolo
it's a male gigolo poor male gigolo on
the streets
so fast his body why is that funny for
some reason
i don't know i've never seen a male
prostituted for some reason
that's the [ __ ] up part it's because
we're like that's that version
sounds funny yeah but with a woman
you're like yeah
well i think there's something it's
interesting because i think that just
the female
prostitute is a much more visible icon
whereas like i'm sure there's got to be
a lot of male gigolos out there and they
yeah the the procedure is probably diff
like
there are spots around la where you can
see people out trying to pick up tricks
and i
haven't ever recognized dudes in that
scenario so i guess that's
that's where that comes from but it
would be the same thing
oh man pretty woman killer hooker takes
some that's a great one thank you
killer hooker needs to be a genre
appreciate it unto itself
i i i can't give it away there's a book
coming out
a wife to someone who we know who might
fulfill that wish
already written and getting published
and hopefully we'll get adapted in a
minute cinema gorilla what's up buddy
tron but cube enough said trombo cube
look i'm not gonna repeat myself
it's tron butt cube john is obsessed
with cube
he's happy to have this back in the chat
right no i
love that for some reason well because
cube
lends itself to a lot of things tron but
cube
well because the thing about this though
is that tron but
cube yeah you've said it right there it
would just be cube at that point with
maybe some slightly different aesthetic
choices and maybe you would have to
access the cube
via video game yeah but uh so yes i'm
actually i'm i'm still i'm down
no of course look at all these waters
popping up thank you waters we are still
gay
all right eric horseman another one okay
so we got two more that we're gonna
go to the stream oh dude yes i'm a
juggalo
pretty woman but with a juggalo eric
horseman is saying goodnight chase
gardner can i chase
e.t the extraterrestrial when he says
ouch it's because he
blew up elliot's
mom's head that's that moon's mom's head
with his red left
finger like on the boys i love it yeah
thanks thanks eric you have contributed
to the horror remake of
et i appreciate that dude dude and and
it's just waiting to happen
it's waiting to happen uh let's see here
conair nerf mac thank you eric
con air broken arrow silver linings
playbook he's saying all three
uh that's uh [ __ ] uh cameron french
booby conair broken arrow several
alliance playbook could all be done
with horror hmm oh yeah con air man
that's like a quarantined
[ __ ] container scary situation
waiting to happen
yeah broken arrow i'm not sure how you
do that silver lighting's playbook i can
see that
especially if you deal with like really
going into those mental illness horror
movies
everyone in the family is in a deep
psychosis of a different variety i'd
love to see an actual pitch on that
those are actually
connor's the only one i could see a
proper one to do a broken arrow and
silver lining sway back i feel you have
to get really creative to really figure
that one out yeah
oh goodnight peter pacheco night peter
pacheco yeah and also i have
seen a few people say spawn but have it
be like a legit actual horror movie
but thank you nerf mac for that can i
just make sure thank you guys for
everything we've contributed gonna
double check
we are done for the night on that but
let's just stay in the stream for a
little bit while
let's talk let's just chat guys thanks
everyone
especially more minutes show some love
to your neighbor
show some love to anissa show some love
everyone's got your back all right we're
reading the comments in real time now
and not just darting and
looking around gamer of the year i want
spawn to be a horror movie but
guys maybe spawn horror movie is gonna
be fun to watch spawn they are is being
done by blumhouse they are gonna make
sure
that it is a horror movie yeah man it's
gonna be spookums you're gonna get what
you want
yeah you're gonna love it it's gonna be
great it'll be great
it's gonna be the best young trip i'm
surprised no one said this until now
transformers but it was like a sci-fi
horror epic but about transformers
battling throughout the city
and trying to escape decepticons like
samurai from megatron the first show
yes a transformers horror movie
seemed like it was gonna kind of have
some of that touch but they are kind of
like they are terrifying
yeah and it should be that way like the
they're they're annoying films to watch
but
if you were able to double down on like
a horror film it could work man
dude and and the thing is every time
i've watched a transformers movie i'm
always
i'm like yeah they they don't capitalize
on the horror of this but if
every time i imagine if this just was
happening in
l.a or something or new york for reals
that would be the
most scary thing yes giant autonomous
robots just knocking stuff down
like that would be horrifying brother
bears a horror sounds great
did chelsea brown say disney's frozen
horror movie was thinking that
uh elsa as evil witch and conquer the
kingdom
yes definitely yes i want it
i think frozen three should be about
them giving up on all this love they've
built
yeah and then just you know or something
goes wrong elsa creates an unholy snow
thing
guys if you know anissa oliva give her
some love give her
some love there's got to be a way for
some of them to get back their dark
original disney stores and
stories and make them as movies i do
agree with that dude i agree as well
i i don't know why we're so afraid to
touch that terrain
like how much power does disney really
have over them i mean i feel like they
sometimes they try
beauty and the beast seems to be one
that's the sad part about beauty and the
beast because beauty and the beast
was a a horror it was already like a
horror movie
and then disney did it and suddenly you
just can't touch beauty and the beast
now
you just can't make your own horror
live-action version of this now good
night
disney has like swept over that image
and now it's associated as only a disney
movie
yeah is that weird because there was
already a beauty in the beast movie
before the
animated movie yeah yeah well in a few
years i was actually curious
about it because a few years back uh
christophe gong
who's the director of the silent hill
movie made a beauty and the beast movie
that at very least it was live action
and it had
effects and stuff i don't know how it
turned out ultimately but it looked at
least like it was
not going to be a the disney movie yeah
you know and so i'd be curious to see it
but yeah
it seems weird to live in a world where
we haven't yet had like a properly
scary or or gritty beauty in the beast
and yet we've had all these ones where
they've done the tale but it's like a
guy
with a cool tattoo yeah i think that
makes him a beast
you know we've done uh ooh gay humphrey
someone's spamming us with that
you just you just deleted it
oh damn i thought you have to
acknowledge him no but
by acknowledging it you take away the
power
not really sometimes oh fair enough i
sometimes i think it gives more power
that's fair you give them attention
honestly john
i forgot what we were talking about in
the last 10 seconds
off into another comment and i was
insane worked deontay said pinocchio
and i think that that would be perfect
they just did a pinocchio trailer they
saw something pop up in my feet for a
pinocchio movie it looked like a horror
movie
you probably yeah that's probably
someone's beating me to my awareness
punch
so deante congratulations although there
is that pinocchio movie that uh roberto
benini tried to make which i've heard is
just
scary because of how bad it is
um game of the year want godzilla to be
a horror movie again the first the first
gareth everyone's actually tried to be
scary
yeah i thought so i like that i think
the thing with the gareth evans one that
went
wrong is with godzilla i think the
reason what took some of the fear out is
that you know he's going to be versing
um my god yeah no moth oh mothra or no
no that well
what's your [ __ ] the names ghidorah
and mothra
the first one oh the the mutos mutos
that's what you should say
yeah where's the original godzilla
you know he's just attacking the city
yeah yeah and i would be interested if
they could pull that off again
they wouldn't do that they had to get
their cinematic universe yeah
i don't know i would love to have a
scary godzilla movie again though that
is like actually
scary anissa if you're not getting some
hate from someone
that means you're doing something wrong
that's right or some [ __ ] like that
you can't keep climbing the mountain you
the higher the mountain you climb the
more arrows that are on your back yeah
because
trust me we see it all the time i i see
hate about us
on videos that's the weird one the one
when you see hate about you on a video
where you're like
this video is i'm not even in this video
just somebody who was like i gotta get
this in here come and get here
yes that's happened to me the other day
it's like what the [ __ ] why uh yeah
darth yo
i mean uh rosie of course you can get a
shout out on it and gene
we must acknowledge jeans really quick
oh and and and
we're not doing any more super chess but
we just happened to get one more so i
want to make sure we acknowledge him
because
he is the gene jeter-ness of them all
and uh
where'd it go and rosie for your
birthday of course we will give you a
special i know i've said we would
oh sorry you're not listening john i was
so listening gene i i lost the genes i
lost the window gene i'm sorry
it's okay we can get it back it's okay
jean jeter saying e.t we talked about et
so much on this appreciate it gene we
talked
many okay let's recap the stream so far
a lot of robin williams a lot of home
alone a lot of toy story podcasting and
a lot of etsy surprisingly
yeah you know it's been the today's
theme e.t has rubbed a lot of people the
wrong way
and uh it's about time that he's taking
a test lennon
had to see you all right all right guys
we're gonna wrap this up for today
um but this was fun it was now let's do
a long goodbye to everyone's names who
pop up in real time i really
really quick i want to thank everyone
who contributed the stream
the ones who like defend people here
i really appreciate that we all like we
don't care of that like how many how big
the viewership gets on these kind of
things we only care about those who are
actually here
right now wanted to keep it positive so
thank you guys and gene dude it's
totally okay
love you man any time to see you is a
good time to see what i i just really
appreciate all the love appreciate
everyone contributed through streamlabs
and super chats here because it does
really all go towards the channel really
it
means a lot thank you yeah and so what i
want to say is say bye to everyone in
real time here
rocketdeal goodbye erica tuesday toy
oh miles parker just gotta read them
goodbye
kevin shepard happy birthday young trip
zoidberger
cinema gorilla chelsea brown tim neil
allen smith
i'll read this one from the other side
same one oh the same one but this one's
way further back eric horseman carissa
ludden movie talks ah
sl7 sj rosie
deontay
kitty oh goodness gracious mind poisoner
3006.
bradley blitzeau oh mimi game of the
year
jeremy jeremy kelly judas judas
thundersteel
all right guys all you thank you so much
damien
ashley hey kevin peace be with you we
will talk to you one of these days
blessings we are endings spread the
kindness spread the joy
go listen to some living tombstone okay
love you guys
oh thank god that stream's done hey i'm
i'm very
very happy to be rid of those people
very happy the stream's over well
there's people i hate to talk to
downstream is good god i feel a lot more
comfortable now that you hit the end
stream button
you can suck a dick that waters guy
in a bad way is not a friendly guy
because denise is the best anissa is
peacock i don't know why you're talking
into your mic when the stream's done
johnny you know
but if it makes you more comfortable oh
sure
i mean we're supposed to be talking to
each other as if
the stream's done with the streams
really it is done i'm just
in this posture and i'm so used to being
in this
boxer since we finished sorry i just
wasn't
you know how long you like finish a
meditation and they tell you to take a
minute before you move
just to reflect on you know your
position
and how you're feeling that's what i did
the streams
how